monsieur le ministre
notre passion pour le Sénat ne vous
lâche pas puisque nous avons passé la
moitié de la soirée tous ensemble et
nous nous retrouvons cet après-midi et
on se retrouve donc pour cette seconde
audition sur le projet de LPM second
audition qui est un peu décalé par
rapport à la première puisque
votre nos premiers échanges visés à bien
éclairer les objectifs de LPM cette
fois-ci c'est déjà de revoir ce texte à
la faveur du vote qui vient d'intervenir
votre solennel à l'Assemblée nationale
un beau succès 48 voix pour c'est quand
même bien
contre 87 et 53 abstention avec le
détail très intéressant du vote des
groupes
alors depuis que nous nous sommes vus
nous avons mené sur le ministre un
certain nombre d'auditions en commission
DGA chef d'état-major représentant de
l'industrie beaucoup de beaucoup
d'auditions beaucoup de rendez-vous
ne rapporteur budgétaires ont achevé un
travail de plusieurs mois pour préparer
ce texte au mieux et je voudrais ici
devant vous les remercier vous savez que
nous avions opté pour une procédure un
peu différente de celle qui avait été
initialement envisagée et là on a eu un
travail d'approfondissement du reste que
je vais faire publier sous forme d'un
rapport regroupant l'ensemble de ces
avis je les remercie parce que ils
apportent un éclairage et une
appréciation qui
m'est très utile dans la préparation de
mon rapport
de votre côté monsieur le ministre vous
avez défendu ce texte devant nos
collègues députés avec le résultat qui
viennent tomber et qui est tout à fait
encourageant les travaux du reste de
l'Assemblée nationale ont été très
intéressants et de qualité je crois d'un
très bon niveau alors nous souhaiterions
aujourd'hui avoir votre analyse sur les
principales modifications du texte
introduit par l'Assemblée nationale et
donc maintenant c'est au tour du Sénat
de discuter ce texte je présenterai mon
rapport à la Commission dans une semaine
et donc il était utile de vous entendre
à nouveau
nos travaux depuis le mois dernier nous
ont confortés dans notre première
analyse nous partons nous aussi d'un
présupposé favorable à ce projet parce
qu'effectivement il poursuit le
redressement de notre effort national et
je n'oublie pas que au terme d'une
deuxième LPM si c'est le site exécuté
dans les conditions que l'on envisage
c'est un doublement des budgets des
armées qui interviendront néanmoins car
il y a toujours un mais néanmoins nous
avons aussi identifié des points de
vigilance qui appelle des précisions
complémentaires peut-être des
modifications nous avons eu encore ce
matin un très long débat entre nous sur
ce sur ces points
évidemment comme un certain nombre de
nos collègues députés je lisais la
tribune de mon collègue Jean-Luc Herriot
à l'assemblée qui compte du reste
beaucoup sur le travail du Sénat
maintenant
comme nombre de nos collègues députés
nous avons des interrogations sur le
cadencement de l'effort proposé avec une
petite question qui Ta rende nos nombre
de nos collègues
pourquoi avoir fait une nouvelle LPM
puisque actuellement nous sommes sur un
train de 3 milliards chaque année et que
dans la nouvelle VPN on
le gouvernement souhaite garder sur les
premières années ce budget de 3
milliards annuels donc vous nous direz
quel est l'intérêt de ce changement on a
aussi une préoccupation sur la nature
des recettes extra budgétaires prévues
pour couvrir les besoins des 413
milliards d'euros sur la période on a
pas mal déjà évoqué ce point et vous
nous avez du reste adressé une lettre à
ce sujet
bon à ce stade monsieur le ministre
nombre de nos collègues ne sont pas
totalement convaincus par votre
argumentation et je pense que nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir nous
sommes également très vigilants sur les
conditions de contrôle par le Parlement
de l'exécution de cette LPM à venir et
ça a fait l'objet de débattre nourri
encore dans tout au long de la matinée
vous savez se laver était un point de
tension qui aurait pu être évité avec
votre prédécesseur et pourtant ce
contrôle par le Parlement qui est la
mission que nous confie la Constitution
approuvé toute son utilité en 2021 nous
avions à cette époque là identifier des
sous-financement dont malheureusement
nous retrouvons les conséquences
aujourd'hui
président de cette commission j'ai
besoin de relayer les préoccupations qui
ont été exprimées par nos collègues un
vrai problème un vrai problème
particulier sur l'accès des
parlementaires aux informations là il
faut véritablement que vous n'éclez nous
éclairiez que vous preniez des
engagements très fermes au cours des
auditions ne rapporter un budgétaires
souvent
en collaborateurs vos équipes ont donné
des réponses évasives c'est aussi
parfois le cas dans les réponses écrites
à notre questionnaire vous étiez engagé
à ce que nous obtenons des réponses
quand faut-il que les réponses soient
précises globalement il devient de plus
en plus difficile depuis le vote de la
LPM actuelle en 2018 de mener à bien
notre mission constitutionnelle de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement je
vais prendre qu'un seul exemple qui a
été longuement évoqué dans les réponses
écrites à notre questionnaire un certain
nombre de réponses sont étiquetés Dr
diffusion restreinte c'est le cas par
exemple de la réponse actualisant le
tableau capacitaire qui figurent dans la
LPM actuelle alors comment comprendre ce
qui était public dans la précédente LPM
et qui devient des fusions récentes
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas acceptable je
vous le dis monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas acceptable et sa conditionnera
l'attitude de nombreux groupes sur ces
sujets il faut que vous serez un jour
vous reprendrez votre mandat de sénateur
donc pensez aussi à votre propre avenir
c'est pas entendu
il faut il faut il faut que le Parlement
puisse exercer son son rôle de contrôle
qui est un rôle constitutionnel or
je pense très sincèrement et nous
pensons de manière unanime que la
classification diffusion restreinte
n'est pas justifiée sur des tableaux
capacitaires qui sont quand même un
élément fondamental pour savoir si la
loi est exécutée ou si elle l'est pas
donc ça c'est un point sur lequel votre
réponse va être évidemment très attendu
et même écouter ce ministre les forts
budgétaires proposé à la nation est
important nous nous en félicitons même
si nous pensons qu'il faut sans doute
améliorer certains points mais
l'importance des saumon je rend
indispensable que le Parlement puisse
exercer la totalité de sa mission de
contrôle sinon tôt ou tard nos
compatriotes car c'est aussi l'opinion
publique que nous devons emporter dans
ce dans cette mobilisation nos
compatriotes risquent un jour de refuser
de soutenir cet effort indispensable
dans le monde toujours plus dangereux
dans lequel nous vivons alors si vous le
voulez bien on va un peu changer la
méthode de l'autre fois c'est à dire
qu'après votre présentation cette
fois-ci c'est un orateur par groupe qui
s'expr et puis après bien sûr notre
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances Dominique de neige et nous
aurons en finale des questions peut-être
d'un certain nombre d'autres sénateurs
mais on va laisser les groupes
politiques s'expliqués puisque les
rapporteurs c'était beaucoup exprimés et
aujourd'hui nous débattons pas du fond
mais du texte qui vient de sortir et qui
vient d'être voté cet après-midi je
rappelle que ces auditions est captées
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président de l'acquisition mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
m'accueillir pour ma cinquième audition
dans le cadre de mes fonctions et
peut-être manière plus précise la
troisième édition dans le cas de
programmation militaire puisque vous
allez choisir et je m'étais engagé
auprès de vous lors de ma première
audition il y a un an plus d'un an
maintenant pratiquement un an justement
dans une méthode plus plus régulière
pour venir dans la commission parfois
dans un format retranscrit parfois dans
un format non retransmis en fonction des
sujets et que je voulais vous redire
puisque je souffle ma première
ministère des armées que c'est une
méthode que je trouve en tout cas qui
produit ses effets soit dans le cadre de
la Commission soit évidemment lorsque la
commission choisie d'ailleurs les murs
vous étiez un certain nombre par exemple
aller au contact d'une force armées sur
les exercices dit Orion qui était aussi
un des moyens pour le Parlement de
contrôler évidemment l'action du
gouvernement et aussi ce qui a mis en
œuvre
merci du cadrage de l'audition je vais
comme je viens souvent je tente à chaque
fois de ne pas redire la même chose
puisque c'est important d'être plutôt
dans quelque chose qui sera incrémental
et d'ailleurs s'il le faut en plus de
évidemment de tout ce qui sera fait sur
l'examen des amendements l'audition en
séance publique moi je suis évidemment
la disposition y compris pendant la
comment dire la discussion du texte il
fallait isoler un thème en particulier
et revenir devant la commission pour
traiter en profondeur quelque chose ça
ne se fait pas toujours enfin je veux
redire ma disponibilité et de bonne foi
et vous avez parlé de la qualité des
débats à l'Assemblée je reste persuadé
que les choix militaires sont des choix
politiques et que la démocratie
représentative à son rôle à jouer en la
matière est plus son rôle à jouer et on
y reviendra peut-être aussi en se
comparant avec d'autres démocraties sur
comment les choses fonctionnent et on a
évidemment des marges améliorations mais
j'ai rien dit deux peut-être redire à
l'ensemble de la commission que mes
propos ne
concerneront pas les articles qui eux
sont liés à l'ancien et au volet
numérique puisque évidemment la
commission des lois et le ministre
Barrow location sera amené à les traiter
je voulais juste que le reciter
évidemment pour mémoire sur le débat
l'Assemblée nationale
avant dernier point sur les
questionnaire que vous avez transmis 87
questions il reste 4 ou 5 questions qui
vont vous arriver entre ce soir et
demain pardon pour les quelques instants
de retard mais vous connaissez ça et
vous comprenez ça je le sais par exemple
par ailleurs très très bien en matière
de bienveillance c'est que évidemment
les équipes qui étaient sur le banc avec
moi pour le débat l'Assemblée nationale
sont les mêmes équipes évidemment qui
raconte au Sénat et donc évidemment il y
a un petit village à faire mais je suis
sûr que vous le comprenez
30 heures de débats en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale 58 heures le débat
en séance 700 amendements comme mission
1700 amendements en séance
ça dit quand même quelque chose de
l'ampleur du débat et de son épaisseur
et au fond j'en retiens plusieurs points
au nom du bicamerisme que je
souhaiterais aussi évoquer devant vous
sur les grands éléments de fond plus ou
moins consensuels mais tel qu'ils ont
été traités et ou des battus dans
l'hémicier que de l'Assemblée nationale
parce que ça peut éclairer je le crois
les travaux dans le cadre de cette
navette parlementaire le premier des
sujets et c'est par là où vous avez
terminé pardonnez-moi donc je vais
peut-être démarrer par là c'est la
question du contrôle parlementaire je
pense que c'est un sujet clé
qui à mon avis comprend plusieurs sous
thèmes le premier évidemment et j'avais
mesuré à quel point cela avait créé plus
qu'une frustration mais un doute dans la
méthode dans la qualité de la relation
entre l'exécutif et le Parlement c'est
évidemment la revoyure et le fait qu'il
y ait un vote sur cette revue
l'Assemblée nationale on est différente
sensibilités politiques mais je crois
avec des échanges entre les groupes des
deux assemblées pour construire
l'amendement on souhaitait prévoir une
revoyure en 2027 avec un vote du
Parlement fin 2027 entendu jusqu'à début
28 partant du principe que un nouveau
président de la République et une
nouvelle législature serait amenée à
remettre évidemment au goût du jour un
certain nombre d'orientation
stratégiques il y a eu un débat
important sur la fréquence
potentielle de ces revoyures certains
les imaginant parfois tous les ans tous
les deux ans je rappellerai à l'ensemble
des sénatrices et des sénateurs que ça
serait tout simplement
abîmer la notion même de loi programme
telle qu'elle avait été imaginée par les
gaullistes dans les années 60 et autant
qu'il faut de la revoyure autant que
trop de revoyure évidemment abîment les
perspectives de visibilité et donc il
faut faire attention ça c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui a retenu la tension du
gouvernement si dans la copie initiale
il n'y avait pas de proposition c'est
parce que le Conseil d'État
rappelez-vous je vous l'avais dit avait
souhaité que nous les retirions
considérons que les contrôles le
contrôle du Parlement ne pouvaient pas
faire l'objet d'une initiative de
l'exécutive dans un taxe initial en
projet de loi mais c'est au Parlement
lui-même de l'introduire cette chose
faite par l'Assemblée nationale c'est un
premier point j'imagine qu'il y aura des
débats et des amendements sur le sujet
en tout cas je tiens à vous redonner
notre notre bienveillance et je prends
ma part aussi de la l'exécution de la
LPM précédente sur ce sujet et que
d'ores et déjà on rentre dans la mêlée
si j'ose dire comme on dit dans
l'infanterie avec une bonne posture la
deuxième des choses mais en cela vous
êtes nombreux à m'avoir aussi interpellé
en amont sur ces sujets ce sont
évidemment sur les grands programmes
européens de coopération industrielle
MGCF pour ne pas les nommer mais qui
évidemment suscite des interrogations
qui parfois évidemment
pose des questions sur la transparence
de ces programmes de bien détourer quels
sont les intérêts de la France sachant
que les intérêts militaires doivent être
en miroir des intérêts industriels enfin
il faut les présenter comme ça aussi le
Parlement et l'Assemblée nationale avec
un effet favorable du Gouvernement a
souhaité que le gouvernement éclaire la
représentation nationale et deux
chambres en 2025 pour le mgcs en 2026 en
tout cas avant le projet de loi de
finance pour 2026 donc à la fin de
l'année 2025 pour le programme Scaff
c'est à dire en clair entre la phase
dite 1 B et la phase 2 être en capacité
pour les armées la DGA et la bit des
Françaises de dire à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat au scénario de
l'Assemblée nationale voici les
conditions dans lequel peuvent se faire
la phase 2 du Scaff conditions
économique industrielle à quoi ressemble
l'avion quelle est la répartition des
des et des compétences de chacun en la
matière ça je pense que c'est un point
clé s'il faut l'affiner évidemment dans
la discussion parlementaire ici il
faudra le faire je pense que c'est
coopération et vous l'avez dit vous-même
plusieurs fois monsieur le Président
elles doivent se faire aussi en lien
avec des parlements ce qui peut être
aussi vous permettra où vous permettrez
d'engager aussi peut-être des
discussions avec vos homologues
parlementaires allemands et permettre
aussi que on soit dans un désormais dans
un dossier qui se fasse d'exécutif
exécutif mais aussi de pouvoir
législatif à pouvoir législatives je
pense en tout cas que c'est sain et que
je pense qu'on ne peut pas laisser
planer trop le doute sur l'intérêt et
l'utilité de ces coopérations pour nous
et donc faut les objectiver sauf à être
compte par principe comme certaines
sensibilités politiques d'extrême gauche
extrême droite ont été lors du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale mais une fois
qu'on a enlevé ces deux catégories de
sensibilité politique derrière et ça
suffit tout simplement d'objectiver les
choses et d'y mettre des critères le
troisième point je viens de me le noter
parce que vous venez d'en parler c'est
l'accès aux informations alors c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé
puisque dans mes fonctions
ministérielles précédentes je n’étais
évidemment pas confronté à ces questions
liées notamment au secret défense et
donc au fond c'est mes 12 mois avec vous
qui m'ont permis aussi de de mieux
appréhender les difficultés je pense
qu'il y a ce qui est vraiment secret et
sur lequel il faut continuer de le
protéger c'est notamment je sais que
c'est parfois difficile mais des crédits
liés à la dissuasion nucléaire sont un
bon exemple mais j'ai eu des échanges
difficiles à l'Assemblée nationale sur
ce sujet donc je recite la jolie phrase
de Pierre Messmer qu'il avait tenu
d'ailleurs dans cette assemblée je crois
que c'était au Sénat c'était pas
l'Assemblée nationale en disant à
certains secrets militaires doivent
correspondre certaines discrétions
budgétaires et de fait si on se compare
avec les Britanniques ou les Américains
pour prendre les trois démocraties
puissance dotées et accessoirement
membre de l'OTAN nous sommes encore les
plus bavards sur le contenu de notre
doctrine nucléaire et même sur les
différents programmes qu'ici à faire
après aller plus loin vous êtes un débat
démocratique il faut juste que
l'ensemble et que nous assumons
collectivement l'affaiblissement de
notre dissuasion a trop en dire puisque
en donnant certaines sommes on dit des
choses sur les contrats opérationnels on
dit aussi des choses sur les efforts de
modernisation de la composante nucléaire
en tout cas moi je
réfute pas le débat politiquement mais
je pense que ça pour le coup c'est du
secret c'est du bon secret deuxième
catégorie de secret c'est le secret lui
au renseignements j'espère avoir
démontré lors de ma première audition à
la DPR que l'habilitation secret défense
pour les parlementaires membres de la
DPR n'étaient pas une coquetterie mais
que je considérais que dès lors que ça
existait il fallait jouer la carte de la
confiance avec la délégation en question
on a évoqué plusieurs sujets j'y reviens
pas ici puisque dans une éditions
retransmise non classifiée mais je pense
que pour le coup la DPR est quand même
un organe où moi je me suis engagé je
l'ai dit et peut-être y venir pas
souvent enfin souvent mais pas longtemps
avec des thèmes très précis qui est à
venir avec les différents responsables
de services en tout cas moi je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit faire
vivre peut-être différemment parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de fantasmes aussi autour
de la DPR entre ceux qui considèrent que
ça va passer loin ce qui considère au
contraire que c'est trop secret et qu'on
sait pas ce qui s'y passe je pense que
tout simplement il faut la faire
fonctionner point et je crois qu'elle a
bien des égards satisfaisantes troisième
des choses
il se trouve qu'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs sont classifiés pour de
bonnes raisons de prime abord
par exemple la question de la
disponibilité technique ou la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
mais quand on y regarde de plus près je
pense qu'on peut faire évoluer les
choses
alors en fait la problème de la DT de la
DTO c'est surtout la transmission des
deux en même temps qui dit quelque chose
puisque évidemment ça permet de
comprendre un certain nombre de choses
sur les contrats opérationnels moi je
vais vous dire le fond de ma pensée
c'est que je pense que sur la DT il faut
qu'on fasse un pas en avant parce que
par ailleurs je vous ai je ne ménage pas
mes efforts pour vous convaincre que la
cohérence doit priver sur la masse et
que par définition on ne peut pas priver
le Parlement de l'indicateur qui permet
de mesurer les efforts de cohérence en
clair j'y reviens toujours le nombre
d'hélicoptères est une chose le nombre
d'hélicoptères qui peut réellement voler
en être une autre et ça évidemment c'est
la DT
au fond je pense qu'il y a des positions
médianes qu'on peut acquitter dans le
cadre de la programmation militaire
faut-il les créer ou pas ça c'est vous
avec votre pouvoir d'amendement qui le
qui le déciderait et j'essaierai de vous
convaincre de trouver peut-être les
rédactions les plus idoine je pense
qu'il y a des choses qu'on n'est pas
obligé de publier mais qu'on peut
remettre tout simplement par voie papier
au président de la Commission ne
rapporteur concerné une fois par an et
qui permet après dans les cadres qui
sont les vôtres de documenter cette
affaire là en tout cas moi je le dis je
pense que sur les indicateurs de la DT
c'est un bon exemple
je pense que ça vaut le coup parce que
ça sera pour moi un des critères sur
lequel je veux que nous soyons jugés
pour la LPM à venir je veux pas dire
mieux alors la capacité à faire et non
pas la capacité à avoir quelque chose de
possédant mais pas très efficace
toujours sur le terrain militaire la
capacité à faire c'est réellement ce que
l'on attend d'une armée d'emploi quant à
la DTO
je vais je vais susciter de l'émotion à
Balard en disant cela devant vous mais
tant pis j'ai un doute sur le
l'efficience de l'indicateur tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui car il est ramené au
contrat opérationnel lesquels parfois
sont très enchevés très
la DTO sur les dissuasion comme vous
avez un certain nombre d'équipements qui
sont dans la dualité conventionnelle et
dissuasion ce n'est pas toujours évident
donc moi j'ai demandé à le ma de me
faire aussi des propositions nouvelles
d'indicateurs et en fonction de ce site
regarder avec le Parlement comment on
peut les comment on peut les couvrir je
pense que tout le monde comprend bien en
revanche qu'on pourrait avoir un système
qui fait que certains indicateurs
existent en tant P et si on devait
basculer dans un temps de guerre il
redevienne par exemple confidentiel en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut être ouvert
la proposition que je fais à la
commission c'est que nous soyons en
confiance et imaginatif voilà c'est de
bonne foi c'est ce que je vous propose
sur l'affaire du contrôle du Parlement
et je suis volontairement long parce que
je pense que l'acceptabilité sociétale
politique des sommes importantes que le
contribuable va consentir aux dépenses
militaires doivent aussi s'accompagner
de quelques résultats d'efficacité et
pour casser davantage encore la baraque
à Balard je pense aussi qu'avoir
quelques indicateurs permet aussi de
maintenir une scène pression déjà une
scène pression sur les équipes ça c'est
mon métier mais aussi une scène pression
par exemple sur les industriels que
j'affectionne mais quand vous les
auditionnerez et que vous aurez donc
accès librement à certains indicateurs
de disponibilité de certains matériels
et bien vous aurez donc aussi l'occasion
de leur mettre aussi une scène pression
sur pourquoi tel ou tel hélicoptère au
hasard a plus de difficulté à voler que
d'autres en dépit des sommes importantes
que vous aurez voté par ailleurs donc il
y a quelque chose à mon avis de saint et
de et d'honnête à avancer sur ce thème
là et si vous en êtes d'accord peut-être
hors retransmission monsieur le
Président avec ceux que vous désignerez
réfléchir à quelque chose qui soit
marquant nouveau efficace dans la
manière de contrôler la future et
programmation militaire ça c'était pour
le contrôle du Parlement une partie a
été faite à l'Assemblée mais j'entends
par votre propos est-ce que je viens de
dire qu'on peut encore aller plus loin
au Sénat et moi à titre personnel je
m'en réjouis parce que une fois de plus
je c'est mon gaullisme qui parle je
rappelle que si le général de Gaulle
Michel Debré permet se met en voulu de
l'autre programmation militaire c'était
précisément pour tout le monde prenne
aussi ça reste responsabilité sur les
sujets militaires et puissent voter en
conscience et emmener la nation avec eux
donc ça je pense que quelque chose de
sain dans cette affaire ensuite mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
plusieurs débats sur des grands sujets
militaires diplomatiques et industriels
nous ont beaucoup occupé lors de la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale
si de prime abord les sujets budgétaires
ont
occupé beaucoup de monde en entrée en
mêlée très vite heureusement ce sont
quand même les sujets militaires qui ont
dominés je le dis parce que c'était ma
crainte c'est au fond de tourner autour
des sujets militaires tournés autour du
vrai sujet qui est le format de nos
armées les alliances qu'est-ce qu'on
attend de l'armée française dans les
années qui viennent si on n'a pas le
débat pendant la programmation militaire
on l'aura jamais je reviendrai sur les
ressources extra budgétaires qui
passionnent beaucoup de monde mais enfin
à la fin des fins une reprogrammation
militaire réussie c'est une loi
programmation militaire dans lequel on
ne se méprend pas sur les objectifs
militaires que l'on confie aux armées et
donc et donc les moyens que l'on assigne
à celle-ci pour remplir la mission dans
le bon ordre la rhétorique s'établit
comme celle-ci premier sujet qui a fait
l'objet d'un débat intéressant mais au
fond non consensuel c'est évidemment la
dissuasion nucléaire
on peut toujours le balayer d'un verre
de main moi j'ai quand même été frappé
de plusieurs types de réflexion des
réflexions constantes de certaines
formations politiques je l'avais indiqué
notamment au président Laurent Fabien
Roussel a eu des propos très très
intelligents en raffirmant son
opposition et la dissuasion que je ne
partage pas mais a remis en perspective
aussi par exemple la position du Parti
communiste français sur la question de
la dissuasion nucléaire bon débat long
exigeants que nous avons eu dans
l'hémicycle mais qui permettait de
clarifier les choses deuxième série
d'oppositions plus feutrée à la
dissuasion mais que je trouve
intéressant mais peut-être dangereux ça
veut dire mais au fond très bien elle
existe aujourd'hui elle est utile elle
fonctionne certainement
comme s'il y avait peut-être un doute
sur le fait qu'elle fonctionne mais ce
qu'elle continuera de fonctionner demain
qui est à la fois un débat qui
m'intéresse parce que on serait de
mauvais responsables politiques à ne pas
s'intéresser à l'évolution de notre
dissuasion à 5 10 15 20 30 ans y compris
avec les énormes sautechnologiques à
venir sur différents sujets et en même
temps c'est déjà le début du
commencement de mais au fond est-ce
qu'il existe pas autre chose par
laquelle on pourrait la remplacer après
tout intellectuellement c'est une
rhétorique aussi intéressante enfin la
remplacer par quoi par quelque chose de
si terrible que peut l'être une arme
nucléaire par quelque chose au fond de
non létal comme certains l'ont dit dans
l'hémicycle bon moi je le dis parce que
c'est important et qu'on peut pas au
moment de cette programmation militaire
se balayer comme ça d'un verre de main
sur la dissuasion et d'ailleurs c'est
très étonnant parce qu'il y a une autre
manière aussi de la remettre en cause
c'est de dire il y a beaucoup d'efforts
budgétaires dans cet élevé enfin
beaucoup valent dissuasion comme chez la
dissuasion n'était pas militaire comme
si la dissuasion ne faisait pas partie
notre voûte nucléaire qui protégeait nos
intérêts vitaux donc moi j'appelle aussi
beaucoup la responsabilité des
parlementaires je le dis de manière un
peu solennelle parce que c'est un sujet
grave et si on y croit et si on veut
qu'elle dissuade c'est pas que un
arsenal technique c'est pas que la
performance de nos marins nous aviateurs
c'est pas que la performance des
ingénieurs c'est pas que la parole du
présent de la République dans le cadre
d'un discours c'est aussi ce que les
formations politiques ou Parlement aussi
dégagent et raconte de cette dissuasion
qui compte aussi beaucoup et ça je crois
que c'est un point important moi je suis
pas là pour donner des bons points des
mauvais points je dis juste ce que les
différentes sensibilités politiques ont
pu dire parce que sous couvert de il y a
pas de débat en fait il y en a et sous
couvert de ça serait plus ou moins
consensuel en fait ça l'est pas et ça je
pense que c'est un point clé parce que
sur la dissuasion elle repose justement
sur ce point là
et on peut pas faire l'économie de ça
troisième sous sujet sous la dissuasion
l'apparition beaucoup du débat autour du
Tian et du traité de non prolifération
avec la tentation pour certains de les
mettre sur le même pied sur la même
étagère or il n'en est rien et j'avais
besoin de penser que précisément les
sujets tient viennent affaiblir les
sujets de prolifération et que autant
que nous sommes très engagés sur le
traité de prolifération de nombreux
littérature autant que toute référence
obtient y compris dans l’alpm comme
certains ont voulu le faire peut-être on
a affaiblissement important c'était bien
amené un statut d'observateur pour voir
pour plus tard c'est intéressant des
armements multilatérales bon enfin non
une puissance de thé aussi des
responsabilités en la matière et donc le
signal avant la commission de la défense
que là aussi c'est mis les armées ne
signalent pas dans la commission de la
défense je vois pas très bien pouvoir le
faire donc ça tout le volume et tout le
volet et le volume d'amendement et de
discussions sur la dissuasion a été
important et je considère que c'était
sain et je considère aussi que le vote
cet après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale
donc il n'y a pas de conclusion
politique ressentir une conclusion
opérationnelle et militaire elle vaut
aussi adhésion en tout cas à ce stade de
l'Assemblée nationale pour la dissuasion
nucléaire de notre pays parce que les
formations politiques ont redit des
choses en la matière et d'ailleurs les
votes ont souvent été guidés sur le
sujet dissuasion nucléaire puisque un
certain nombre d'oppositions ce sont
légitimés en tout cas dans cette
explication de vote deuxième des choses
j'étais frappé de la dureté pour ne pas
dire de la violence des débats autour de
nos alliances et de nos coopérations
européennes je parle pas d'un doute sur
ce qu'il faut faire le SCAF dans ce
périmètre là ça c'est un débats
techniques industriels économique
politique à la rigueur ça c'est autre
chose non sur le fait par exemple de
d'avoir une liste de pays comme vous
l'avez dans le rapport indexé qui cite
que la France entretient des
partenariats privilégiés avec l'Italie
la Belgique l'Allemagne l'Espagne la
Grande-Bretagne les États-Unis etc et
des amendements en cascade pour
supprimer l'Allemagne de la liste
je vais quand même en alerte aussi les
parlementaires et c'était pas un ou deux
amendements isolé qui aurait été balayé
en deux minutes je parle de plusieurs
heures de débat dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale au fond qui
considère que sous forme aussi un peu
d'anti-américanisme à peine déguisé par
la relation à Berlin
remettant en cause au fond un certain
nombre de grands préceptes qui me
semblaient pour le coup assez consensuel
jusqu'à lors depuis l'après-guerre
Quatrième République 5e République
jusqu'à nos jours il n'en est rien et
comme vous avez une responsabilité aussi
sur ces sujets dans le cas de la navette
et du bicamerisme je pense utile aussi
de vous le rappeler je n'y reviens pas
pour autant il était entendu que
certains sujets de souveraineté
capacitaires méritaient d'être traité
nous l'avons fait que il fallait
sûrement mieux définir certains de nos
intérêts en matière de coopération le
sujet de l'Europe de la défense est un
sujet qui faisait réagir l'ensemble des
banques dans un sens ou dans un autre
bref en tout cas là il y a matière et je
ne parle même pas de la question de
l'OTAN qui pour le coup un sujet qui
n'est absolument plus consensuel ce qui
est donc mon troisième sous-point l'OTAN
soit l'approche est très politicienne
c'est compliqué d'avoir un débat de
qualité sur le temps là où nous avons eu
un débat de qualité sur la dissuasion
nucléaire et donc j'ai donné un avis
favorable à un amendement de la France
insoumise parce que je considérais qu'il
fallait le faire pour que le
gouvernement ait nos forces armées
produisent un rapport sur les effets et
le bilan de la réintégration du
commandement intégré par la France il y
a maintenant 10 ans en essayant
d'objectiver les choses que l'on soit
pour ou que l'on soit contre en matière
de contrat opérationnel d'un
téopérabilité de planification de
plantes défense de la place de la France
des armées des officiers français dans
les organigrammes de l'OTAN mais je
pense que on peut pas se passionner pour
le tableau capacitaire de la LPM si on
ne se passionne pas pour nos alliances
et même pour détourer notre souveraineté
il faut être au clair sur ce que l'on
veut faire à plusieurs est-ce que l'on
ne souhaite pas faire avec les autres je
crois que c'est absolument clé et ça
pour le coup c'est une de mes grandes
déceptions pour être honnête avec vous
depuis le début c'est que en fait on n'a
pas se miroir on n'a pas le miroir
contrat opérationnel tableau capacités
c'est toujours une entrée par un des
trois tableaux alors qu'en fait la LPM
c'est un tout avec ces trois facettes là
et ça pour le coup c'est un des enjeux
pour moi d'essayer avec vous dans
l'ordre de la discussion au Sénat parce
que pour la nation pour notre opinion
publique même pour les armées c'est là
où réside la clé de la cohérence globale
du modèle tel qu'il a été imaginé dans
les années 60 sinon on ne comprend pas
ce que permet SMER a voulu faire par
exemple pour l'armée de terre dans les
années 60 bon donc tout n'est pas qu'à
faire de l'argent tout n'est pas capable
d'équipement c'est aussi cette question
qui est posée et ça je dois bien avouer
que ça a été beaucoup plus difficile
autre sujet non consensuel
c'est évidemment la question du contrôle
les exportations d'armes par le
Parlement
je n'en dis pas plus mais une volonté au
fond de se substituer l'exécutif dans la
manière d'autoriser les licences ou
alors à posteriori bon je sais que c'est
un sujet qui est pas forcément conscient
seul non plus ici enfin je le signale
parce que on peut pas parler de BITD si
on parle pas d'exportation un moment
donné le modèle repose aussi sur des
capacités à réussir l'export évidemment
ça pose aussi des questions
diplomatiques qui sont évidemment nobles
bien des égards enfin ça a été quand
même évidemment aussi un débat important
j'étais frappé pour continuer
cinquième point
mais ça m'a frappé aussi cette nuit ici
sur le peu de remarques sur le rôle des
missions confiées aux armées ou sur nos
bases par exemple à l'étranger
ça je soit c'est parce que c'est
complètement consensuel et je m'en
réjouis ce qui devrait donc aider le
reste de la discussion soit au fond
parce que ce n'est pas compris ou que ça
ne veut pas être traité je le dis comme
je le pense et cette nuit je me suis
servi du sénateur caddique me pris de
bien vouloir m'excuser et du sénateur
Laurent pardon mais enfin c'était
intéressant de voir sur le rôle de nos
bases en Afrique entre le président
Laurent qui souhaitait fermer les bases
son opinion et c'est bien respectable et
le sénateur caddic qui souhaitait faire
intervenir nos militaires dès qu'on
avait des intérêts économiques qui
pouvaient être en danger je le fais vite
en fait on voit bien quand même qu'on
est sur c'est pas qu'on est sur deux
modèles c'est qu'on est sur deux visions
complètement opposées de la doctrine
d'emploi de nos bases et de nos forces
armées en Afrique et ce qui est vrai
pour les bases et vrai aussi pour la
plupart des missions ou des contrats
opérationnels je parlais d'Atalante
cette nuit dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
pratiquement pas parlé il y a évidemment
la réassurance sur floriental le temps
ça carène quand même un certain nombre
de choses niveau vegan niveau division
je pense Orion nous a tous permis de
comprendre pour le coup cohérence et
masse ce que ça voulait dire j'ai envie
de tout à l'heure la tribune de
l'Assemblée que au fond peut-être que ça
aurait été historique de se projeter
vers un niveau cordes armée il l'a dit
en fin de discussion pourquoi pas enfin
pourquoi faire je rappelle que la
dernière fois qu'on a fait corps d'armée
c'était en Algérie est-ce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'on va faire je suis pas
certain donc moi je mets aussi des pieds
dans le plat parce que on peut toujours
après parler pendant des heures des
marges frictionnelles des reports de
charges etc le vrai sujet de fond quand
même c'est qu'est-ce qu'on attend des
missions pour nos forces armées ça je
dois bien avouer que le débat est en
partie inabouti et que sur le terrain on
l'a eu président pour le coup c'était
intéressant et que de manière non
classifiée on peut l'avoir complètement
ici et le cas échéant s'il le faut avec
le séma j'y mets quand même un bémol les
seules missions qui ont fait l'objet de
débat ça ne vous surprendra pas
c'est sentinelles pour mieux dire que
les forces armées ne devaient pas
intervenir sur le territoire national et
harpie pour mieux dire qu'il fallait en
faire plus alors qu'on était sur le
territoire national
ce qui veut bien dire que cette affaire
endoctrine n'est pas si simple à traiter
et donc je redis ce que vous savez déjà
sur sentinelle sur harpie les choses
sont en plus délicates que qu'un décès
est intervenu pendant la loi
programmation militaire en tant qu'elles
sont l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale
mais c'est un sujet qui est à mon avis
compliqué la question des missions
intérieures est une question aussi
complexe que la question des opaques et
la question de toutes les missions que
l'on peut mener par ailleurs le
porte-avion évidemment c'est largement
invité dans les débats à l'Assemblée
nationale
avec des amendements aussi
réconciliables que ceux qui voulaient
qu'on le supprime tout de suite et ceux
qui en veulent un deuxième
qu'est-ce que dit maintenant le texte en
sortant de l'Assemblée nationale
plusieurs choses que le p.a.g est
confirmé donc le successeur du Charles
de Gaulle j'ai exprimé de nombreuses
fois devant vous j'y reviens pas ça m'a
permis de reclarifier aussi l'utilité
d'un porte-avion dans les différentes
missions et contrats opérationnels je
pense qu'on a on ne parle pas assez de
sécurité maritime d'accès à certaines la
liberté maritime beaucoup parler devant
vous en mousse Babel Mandel etc c'est un
point absolument clé la question aussi
du partage des rôles on revient à l'OTAN
les mêmes qui voulaient supprimer le
porte-avion sont ceux qui veulent sortir
du commandement intégré de l'OTAN il
faut être cohérence soit d'un côté on
laisse les clés au groupe ironaval
bouche américain en mer Méditerranée et
on laisse les Américains faire un autre
place soit on a notre propre groupe
aéronaval et on considère qu'on a notre
propre capacité à agir en Méditerranée
bon
je vous assure que tout ça mérite quand
même un peu de cohérence désormais parce
que sinon on ne s'en sort pas et ça pour
le coup c'est un point qui me semble
intéressant je me suis aussi engagé pour
des effets d'opportunité à ce qu'on
fasse la transparence par un rapport au
Parlement monsieur le Président sur la
faisabilité du coût d'un deuxième
porte-avion je m'explique ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on veut un deuxième je pense
qu'on n'est pas capable de le payer pour
être très clair mais pour des raisons de
transparence comme on va objectiver les
coûts du premier chaufferies nucléaire
enfin en clair plus on va avancer plus
on va être capable de définir le
programme du ONG plus on est capable en
revanche en théorie et de manière
conceptuelle de donner le chiffre de ce
que coûterait un deuxième c'est ce que
les parlementaires m'ont demandé c'est
pas pour pas parce qu'on demande le prix
qu'on sait se le payer ensuite c'est le
principe du devis
intéresse j'en suis persuadé oui je veux
bien
alors pour le coup c'est simple un pet
le PNG est une classe à 10 milliards
d'euros et en revanche c'est les travaux
qui vont être menés dans les 18 mois qui
viennent qui va vous permettre d'affiner
les sommes
que j'espère pas la hausse bon et que au
mieux tout ça vous avez un sujet de
souveraineté industrielle parce que les
chaufferies évidemment sont les
chaufferies avec un savoir-faire qui
correspond aussi au chaufferies que nous
avons sur les SNLE et sur les Sénats et
qu'évidemment on se paye aussi il faut
qu'on le reconnaisse tous ensemble notre
autonomie française c'est-à-dire que
forcément si on achetait américain ça
coûterait moins cher il faut s'y mettre
les pieds dans le plat tout ça coûte
aussi un peu plus cher parce que c'est
franco-français en autonomie exclier la
dissuasion pour faire vite sur le PNG
mais je pense que pour le coup faudra
faire la vérité des prix parce que pour
être aussi très honnête il y a trop de
légendes trop de fausses rumeurs sur la
question du porte-avion pour qu'on ne
vienne pas le documenter doctement
devant la présentation nationale après
chacun a son opinion sur cette affaire
et que derrière le porte-avion c'est la
question du groupe et on avale des
missions qui sont confiées évidemment je
rappelle que l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui veulent se rendre sur
le Charles de Gaulle aujourd'hui pour
mieux comprendre les différentes
missions sont les bienvenus puisque
parfois un cas pratique concret en mer
Méditerranée ou dans l'océan Indien vaut
toutes les démonstrations du ministre en
commission autre débat qui a suscité
pardon je suis un peu long au moment où
je suis précis beaucoup de de remarques
ou de questions de manière là aussi très
irré-conciliable c'est sur la part
d'externalisation que le ministère des
armées doit consentir
entre ceux qui n'en veulent strictement
aucune c'est à dire y compris pour le
MCO c'est-à-dire y compris sortir les
industriels du maintien en conditions
opérationnelles ce qui me semble
imposable parce que ça n'a jamais été le
cas dans l'histoire de nos armées mais
enfin pourquoi pas jusqu'à ceux qui
considèrent qu'au fond sur certaines
tâches l'externalisation peut avoir du
bon surtout quand elles sont pas
opérationnelles elles sont une vocation
très civiles bon là aussi on a pris un
certain nombre d'engagement je vous
renvoie au texte pour ne pas être trop
long ensuite à la cavalcade peut-être
beaucoup de sujets débattus mais que je
crois plus ou moins consensuel c'est à
dire une volonté d'améliorer les choses
mais avec un don tact pour que les
choses puissent avancer dans le bon sens
1 la question des réserves tant sur la
doctrine que sur la cible je pense que
cette affaire est de plus en plus
comprise comme étant des chantiers de
transformation du modèle d'armée et ça
c'est clé la famille des sujets blessés
et c'est ça un amendement du
gouvernement mais je l'avais fait aussi
parce que j'ai pris quelques engagements
même assez
d'un amendement du Gouvernement assez
grand dans lequel sur le quantique sur
l'intelligence artificielle sur le cyber
sur le newspace là aussi tout était dans
la copie mais il y a une volonté d'être
plus précis mais évidemment je me suis
exécuté puisque la copie est bonne donc
autant le temps de faire savoir et
montrer justement à quoi correspondent
nos efforts en matière d'innovation on a
procédé aussi la mise à jour à la
clarification du tableau sur le terrain
capacitaire
nous avons corrigé monsieur le sénateur
père coquille sur le drone
SDT merci de l'avoir remarqué avec
bienveillance je suis revenu évidemment
sur le sujet
neuron mais je sais que je le referai
devant vous parce que c'est un des
points à mon avis très important de la
transformation du standard F5 etc dans
les années qui viennent la mise à jour
évidemment du tableau capacitaire lié
aux aides à l'Ukraine ça je m'étais
engagé auprès de vous à le faire dans la
navette c'est fait sur évidemment la
cible Jaguar enfin scorpion de manière
globale suite aux sessions de vabes et
des mx10r pour l'Ukraine les
négociations avec l'industrielle qui se
sont bien terminées sur Iris qui nous
permet de mettre un satellite
supplémentaire sur cette segment
opérationnel là avant 2030 donc autant
de sujets sur lesquels je sais que je
reviendrai vous les trajectoires
financières évidemment mais j'en viens
là mais c'est là le résultat du reste
donc pas un préalable j'ai
malheureusement dire parce que notre
armée française est une armée d'emploi
c'est pas là pour remplir des hangars
mais bel et bien pour faire en sorte que
les missions que l'on confie aux armées
fonctionnent
plusieurs séries de Souss sujets
certains me semble consensuels
carburant opérationnel je le dis
d'autant plus que c'est le Parlement qui
est imposé au gouvernement G10 la
disposition et qu'elle fonctionne donc
bon c'est vous parlant c'est vous mais
moi
donc c'est le Sénat donc moi j'ai
redescendu le dispositif en disant qu'il
fonctionnait je trouve pas utile d'y
retoucher puisqu'il fonctionne
précisément c'est un bon exemple deux je
pense avoir aussi refait la
démonstration que les deux pour cent du
PIB étaient intéressants mais pour une
armée comme la nôtre ne pouvait pas être
le seul critère qu'il fallait regarder
et pour cause lorsque le PIB a chuté en
2020 pendant le covid on avait les deux
pour cent du PIB en crédibilité et que
avec le prochain testable qui montre que
la croissance repart ça peut redilater
le comment dire l'agenda de la atteindre
pour lire la cible de 2% bon en plus les
2% puissance de T puissance non dotée
bref donc évidemment on regarde le temps
c'est un sujet sur lequel je pourrais
venir devant vous et puis les marches où
je me suis efforcé de réexpliquer que
évidemment les correspondait aussi à des
besoins et sur lequel des questions se
sont posées sur lequel je me suis engagé
de revenir devant le Sénat notamment sur
la part de la préparation opérationnelle
des forces dans cette et notamment du
rythme de cette préparation qui donc ma
fameuse réexpliquer comment en matière
capacitaire les marches avaient été
construites ce qui a amené justement
l'Assemblée nationale à poser des
questions davantage dans la préparation
des forces les ressources extra
budgétaires sur lequel LR en commission
à l'Assemblée nationale on souhaitait
introduire un mécanisme de protection
des gens très bien
on prend acte de commencer construit
mais au fond si vos prévisions sont
mauvaises qu'est-ce qui se passe rien
engagement de budgétiser tout simplement
en gestion on le voit de finance si
jamais les prévisions devaient être plus
faibles je vais mieux vous dire que
toute façon c'est assez facile dans la
mesure où nous avons fait des prévisions
très prudentes sur les ressources extra
budgétaires qu'elles ont toujours existé
même si tout le monde semble découvrir
qu'elles existent désormais mais en tout
cas là aussi c'est un sujet que je crois
désormais entendu alors vous avez dit
que je ne suis pas toujours convainc
quand sur cette affaire là en même temps
tous celles et ceux qui m'ont porté la
contradiction à l'Assemblée ne m'ont pas
convaincu en quoi ce n'était pas
convaincant pour être complètement
transparent pense que les marges
frictionnelles elles ont toujours existé
sauf à considérer qu'elles n'existeront
plus demain c'était du soir cette
absurde ça serait faux que les reports
de charge serait inutiles c'est plus la
peine de me parler d'inflation si on
vient abîmer un des rares outils qui
permet au ministère des armées et qui
était conquis de haute face à Bercy dans
le passé par mes prédécesseurs donc on
peut remettre en cause le report de
charge mais ça serait donc un mauvais
coup aux armées parce que ça serait un
des outils pour gérer l'inflation qui
serait en moins et puis quand on recède
du SSA c'est sûr que elle pourrait
repartir dans le budget général de
l'État sans passer par la case ministère
des armées je vois pas en quoi ça serait
une bonne nouvelle donc au fond sur les
ressources extra budgétaires
l'amendement des LR en commission à
l'Assemblée permet je le crois de
sanctuariser les choses en tout cas je
pourrais répondre une nouvelle fois s'il
le faut à vos questions en la matière
beaucoup de sujets sur la transition
écologique et les armées sur le rôle des
armées liées au réchauffement climatique
qui n'est pas sans lien avec le
patchoutremer et qui est un bon sujet
évidemment dans les contrats
opérationnels ensuite beaucoup de
thématiques ont été
vus rapidement trajectoire ressources
humaines question mémorielle ancien
combattants contrat opérationnel je le
disais mais évidemment tout ça n'a pas
forcément fait l'objet de beaucoup
d'amendements alors que ça aurait pu par
ailleurs le nécessité en tout cas
susciter les débats des fois de suicider
les amandes voilà pardon de ma précision
on bavardages mais je me croyais bon de
repartir du bon pied avec vous sur la
discussion de ce projet de loi en
éclairant la Haute Assemblée des
évolutions notables mais aussi de la
forme des débats l'Assemblée nationale
qui dit quelque chose aussi de ce que
pourrait être la forme des débats au
sein
monsieur le ministre de ce compte-rendu
des débats de l'Assemblée nationale il
n'a échappé à personne que la
composition politique de du Sénat est
sensiblement différente de celle du de
l'Assemblée donc à la fois les réactions
les prises de position et peut-être
suffisamment seront aussi parfois de
nature un peu différente même si les
préoccupations peuvent être semblables à
bien des égards alors donc nous allons
avoir un représentant par groupe et je
vais commencer par les républicains pour
le compte duquel s'exprime Cédric permet
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale ont
été riches je retiens notamment
plusieurs préoccupations exprimées à
cette occasion que nous partageons et
riche et de bonnes tenues je crois que
le président l'a souligné à nombreuses
reprises au cours des différentes
auditions on a été pour ceux qui ont pu
suivre la nuit depuis leur poste de
télévision un certain nombre de débats
particulièrement
agréablement surpris en tout cas par la
tenue des débats sauf sur celui sur la
dissuasion nucléaire mais on va pas
revenir dessus c'était assez surprenant
la volonté d'améliorer le contrôle
parlementaire d'abord sur l'exécution de
la programmation militaire c'est un des
sujets que qui nous préoccupent car
naturellement le vote d'une LPM ce n'est
pas un blanc sain et sa mise en oeuvre
compte au moins autant que les
intentions qu'elle expriment s'agissant
de son actualisation nous partageons le
souhait de l'Assemblée nationale de ne
pas revivre la situation de 2021 qui
vous l'avez entendu ici à plusieurs
reprises nous a un peu traumatisé
la tension portée à la montée en
puissance de la réserve avec désormais
une cible intermédiaire à 80 000
réservistes à l'horizon 2030 beaucoup de
questions entourant cette montée en
puissance qui porte seule l'évolution du
format des armées reste néanmoins posées
comme le financement la formation
l'équipement ou encore l'emploi la
tension porte également à la situation
de nos outre-mer qui se retrouvent en
première ligne face au bouleversement du
monde
si les débats ont été intenses et ont
permis des précisions et des compléments
utiles ils n'ont pas abouti à une
modification substantielle des grands
équilibres du texte je pense en
particulier au disposition relatives à
l'économie de la défense qui n'ont pas
été modifiées en dépit des questions de
fond qu'elle pose pour nos industriels
je pense aussi bien sûr à celles qui
concerne la programmation financière
proprement dite vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du porte-avion donc je ne vais
pas y revenir mais c'est un sujet qui a
été évoqué largement par nos collègues
ce matin j'imagine que certains vont y
revenir
sur ce sujet c'est un point important
il y a évidemment eu un amendement très
utile et pertinent de nos collègues
galères sur la compensation des
ressources extra budgétaires éventuelles
éventuellement manquantes il n'y a pas
grand chose à signaler sur ce sujet ça a
été un point marquant également dans ces
conditions il pouvait pas y avoir de
révolution non plus sur l'aspect
capacité plusieurs amendements
significatifs on est néanmoins étaient
adopté concernant leur rafale et le SCAF
tout d'abord le gouvernement a fait
voter un amendement prévoyant la
présentation d'un rapport d'étape sur
les travaux réalisés pendant la phase 1
B et un amendement prévoyant que le
standard F5 du Rafale accompagné d'un
drone
issu des travaux du démonstrateur neuron
seraient développé au cours de la LPM
faut-il voir dans ces amendements le
signe que la France se prépare à ce que
le Scaff ne soit pas opérationnel en
2040 pouvez-vous par ailleurs nous
préciser le calendrier et les sommes
envisagés pour le développement du
standard F5 alors qu'il est actuellement
prévu de porter le Rafale au standard F4
concernant le programme Scorpion vous
avez déposé un amendement pour accélérer
la livraison de 92 griffons et 38
jaguars afin de compenser la session à
l'Ukraine c'est un point important parce
que la question est de savoir si
s'attendrait à démontrer que s'il y a
des commandes l'industrie est finalement
en capacité de les livrer
pouvez-vous est-ce que également nous
apporter des précisions sur les
cadencement envisagées pour ces
livraisons le ratio de recomplètement
combien de véhicules neufs pour combien
de véhicules anciens et sur le mécanisme
de financement interministériel envisagé
puisque ce financement des dons à
l'Ukraine évidemment un sujet absolument
fondamental concernant le porte-avion
j'en ai parlé concernant le système de
drone aérien pour la marine le
rapporteur de l'Assemblée nationale la
modifications
la rectification la rectification pardon
d'une erreur matérielle et la portée de
8 à 10 est-ce que vous confirmez qu'il
s'agissait d'une erreur dans le tableau
capacitaire par ailleurs le système
aurait semble-t-il connu quelques
difficultés techniques lors des phases
décès pouvez-vous nous en dire davantage
mais je crois qu'il avait déjà posé
cette question la dernière fois j'avais
pas eu vraiment de réponse enfin
concernant les efforts budgétaires
prioritaires le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement précisant que les efforts sur
le domaine thématiques pouvaient être
inclure pour partie des financements
également présenter au titre des efforts
capacités est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner davantage de précision sur ses
chevauchements budgétaires et en outre
des précisions ont été apportées pour
apparemment sur l'in plutôt espérer que
vous fassiez le même lors de la
discussion au Sénat sur d'autres
objectifs comme les drones la défense
surface R ou les munitions parce que je
rappelle que pour l'instant nous
disposons de gros patchs budgétaires 5
milliards pour les drones 16 milliards
pour la les munitions sans aucun détail
et plus largement sur la décomposition
de l'agrégat équipements programme
budget et budget affectés enfin Monsieur
le Ministre le président n'a parlé tout
à l'heure nous avions demandé le tableau
capacitaire et nous avons demandé les
programmes manquants dans le tableau
capacité pardon et les points de passage
intermédiaires pour tous les programmes
23 25 27 30 et 35 et nous avons reçu des
programmes manquants mais pas les points
de passage intermédiaire ça nous
intéresserait évidemment d'avoir ce
degré de détails merci beaucoup
merci Cédric pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain rachidemale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez commencé par dire que
l'aspect financier n'était qu'une
conséquence
et je partage le point de vue mais comme
je vais être un peu taquin je vais
commencer par expliquer que c'est
surtout là-dessus que beaucoup ont
communiqué en expliquant que c'est un
montant historique tout à l'heure
je me suis permis de relire notamment
votre intervention au démarrage de la
discussion à l'Assemblée je pense c'est
important de le redire et c'est vrai que
vous avez raison de le dire le point de
départ c'est surtout le monde tel qu'il
est ou tel qu'il va arriver devant nous
et je crois que on n'a pas eu c'est
peut-être par là que je vais commencer
la discussion nécessaire je crois
préalable à tout le reste
elle a pas été possible je le redis je
l'avais dit lors des examens des crédits
de la mission défense à l'époque au
Sénat parce que c'est vrai et vous
l'avez dit il n'y a pas eu la révision
de l'actuel LPM pas la pression de
l'actuel et le pain puisque je rappelle
qu'elle est toujours en cours à ce stade
et ça on peut le regretter c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas eu ce travail là et par
ailleurs on peut aussi regretter même si
je partage pas ce que vous indiquer à un
moment donné c'est que sur la revue
National stratégique c'est vrai que je
le redis elle était plutôt en chambre
et en tout cas attention assez peu pour
pas dire pas le Parlement puisque
d'ailleurs nous-mêmes au Sénat nous
avions refusé d'être dans les groupes de
travail et c'est un peu une découverte
et je crois que c'est un peu ça mais on
aura l'occasion dans des matchs dans
l'hémicycle mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu sale le sujet que nous avons devant
nous c'est parce que comme nous avons
pas pu collectivement partager l'actuel
loi de programmation militaire et pas le
monde tel qui sera aujourd'hui demain ou
après-demain que nous avons peut-être
aussi quelques hiatus quelques
différences en tout cas quelques débats
entre nous parce que c'est vrai que vous
le disiez dans votre texte vous dites
que cette loi de programmation militaire
ne suppose pas une rupture fondamentale
avec historique elle vise au contraire à
revenir à sa force conceptuelle initiale
alors vous citez souvent
le général de Gaulle je vous l'ai déjà
dit moi je suis plutôt goolien que
gaulliste mais je rappelle que ma
feuille petit parce que vous avez
souvent eu l'occasion dans l'hémicycle
de rappeler les les tel ou telle partie
ma famille politique c'est effectivement
François Mitterrand Lionel Jospin
François Hollande qui a également sur
ses questions là les trois ont été
totalement la hauteur
je crois la hauteur des questions
militaires en assurant à chaque fois le
renforcement nos capacité de défense le
renforcement de capacités de projection
le choix la diffusion nucléaire je pense
c'est important de le dire une fois que
je dis ça je pense que c'est là qu'on a
on a ce débat là donc il le sentiment
que moi j'ai c'est pas de revenir à la
formation initiale c'est plutôt nos
projeter si je peux me permettre et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les théâtres un peu conséquent
on le sait ce qui se passe sur le
territoire européen avec une un pays
doté dans un monde nucléaire membre des
Nations permanent du Conseil de sécurité
des sciences unique qui décide
d'attaquer ce qui se passe sur le
continent je veux dire africain
notamment comme parfois aussi j'en veux
dire terrain de seconde main pour
d'autres puissances que sont notamment
la Russie la chez nous ou la Turquie et
puis n'adopacifique et c'est vrai que
j'aurais aimé moi en tout cas nous
aurions aimé nous que ce point-là soit
le point de départ de toute la
conception et donc une fois qu'on s'est
dit ça une fois qu'on sait nos capacités
financières limitées une fois qu'on a
fait le choix de maintenir l'ensemble
notre armée complète certes parfois
échantillère mais en tout cas on la
maintient et là-dessus nous partageons
alors vous avez raison la question se
pose des alliances réellement et donc
pour la question notamment l'OTAN je
suis d'accord c'est une bonne chose
l'amendement que vous avez accepté mais
je crois qu'il faut aller plus loin il
faut s'interroger sur quel rôle plus en
profondeur dans l'OTAN pour la France il
y a certaines de clubs sur lequel on
pourra discuter mais je crois que c'est
une vraie question que nous avons devant
nous dire un moment donné qu'est-ce
qu'on fait à partir du moment nous
sommes plus en capacité c'est faut le
dire d'avoir une désaction totalement
seule dans le monde et donc la question
de l'OTAN est ce qu'on y fait dedans me
semble essentielle et en conséquence
également la question des partenariats
que vous avez évoqué et je crois que ça
c'est des éléments qui nous sommes
importants et qu'il faudra évoquer pour
ne pas être trop long quelques points
supplémentaires c'est vrai que la
question du contrepartmentaire est
essentielle
il faudrait pas que nous vivions je l'ai
dit l'actuel LPM on nous a expliqué
gentiment que c'est dommage mais on se
passera du Parlement et c'est vrai que
moi je note les efforts qui sont les
vôtres quand on a de l'accès à
l'information puisque si il n'y a pas
cet information là alors on pourra
mettre toutes les causes que nous
souhaitons cela ne marchera pas et j'en
suis convaincu d'autant plus que le rôle
Parlement c'est quand même de voter la
loi le contrôle mais également les balu
sont les plus publics je crois que c'est
important
sur sur donc j'ai dit donc le format des
armées je l'ai dit donc les conséquences
je crois que la question des
conséquences ça me semble essentielle
autant question européenne avec je crois
que quand on fait le tour différents
pays européens on a le sentiment parfois
cette que peut-être que la porte
d'entrée serait plutôt l'OTAN que la
politique européenne de défense je crois
que c'est un vrai sujet que nous avons
devant nous et qu'il faudra m'en
trancher et avoir les en tirer les
conséquences
et pour ne pas être trop long je vais
revenir d'un mot
sur l'économie guerre moi je suis très
dubitatif parce que nous ne sommes pas
en guerre je pense qu'il faut plutôt de
la capacité plutôt notre capacité à
avoir un outil industriel qui se qui est
une capacité de se mettre au niveau je
crois des enjeux plus que des
comédiaires je crois qu'il serait bon de
ne pas utile ce terme-là la France n'est
pas en guerre et tant mieux je crois
qu'il faut l'avoir sur les patchs je
crois que je l'ai dit on l'a fait on a
commis rapport quelques-uns je crois que
la question n'adopacifique est
essentielle
parce que le pivot le pivotage je sais
pas comment il faut dire le fait que le
pivot des Américains bascule vers
l'Indopacifique veut dire que la
question du front j'ai envie de dire
entre guillemets européen se pose et
donc notre rôle plus à cet endroit là et
peut-être plutôt en soutien notamment
sur nos
ancrages ou nos entités territoriales
sur la dopacique plus que d'aller
nous-mêmes être j'ai envie de dire face
à la Chine dans nos capacités nos
capacités qui sont les nôtres et ces
questions là c'est vrai que c'est un peu
dommage qu'on n'a pas eu le temps c'est
pas le point d'épargne de nos opérations
et pour m'arrêter là sur la question des
finances puisque c'est la conclusion ce
que vous avez invité à faire je note les
413 j'ai entendu le débat le rapporteur
et là sur les 13 nous avons eu le débat
à l'époque avec avec le président du
Conseil des finances publiques sur les
13 milliards vous avez vos réponses il y
a eu des avancées à
l'Assemblée donc là dessus je crois que
nous allons pouvoir avancer
après si on prend 413
je me suis livré un petit un petit
calcul mais qui de fait vous aurez
l'occasion de m'expliquer qu'il n'est
pas assez juste mais quand même je
rappelle que l'actuel PM comprend les
années 24 et 25
qui si j'en fais comme ça calcule c'est
un vrai 97 milliards
et donc si comme la nouvelle LPM reprend
24 et 25 peut-être qu'on peut déjà
neutraliser ce qui ferait un peu moins
donc des 413
on pourrait y rajouter effectivement les
30 les 30 sur la question de l'inflation
et à ce stage je garde je garde de côté
les reports pour charge ce que je fais
là n'est pas une volonté de critiquer
quand on est bien mais je crois de
plutôt une volonté de transparence qui
va à chacun de dire la réalité de ce que
nous mettons et avec ce que vous avez
dit effectivement la question de
l'acceptabilité sociale économique du
montant qui conséquent donc là-dessus
nous en parle de sujet mais je crois
qu'il sait mieux de communiquer sur ce
chiffre là plutôt que les 413 c'est ça
que je voulais dire puisque si encore
une fois vous retirez les années 24 25
ils étaient déjà dans un pas je crois
pas faire la double comptabilité mais
voilà et puis pour terminer donc en tout
cas pour notre groupe donc nous serons
dans une logique de bonification de la
loi de programmation militaire et c'est
donc à l'issue de ce travail là à la
fois j'ai envie de dire nous ferons ce
travail là en commission bien sûr en
séance que nous déterminerons notre
notre vote le monde venu
je vous propose de chemise de répondre
de par deux parce que sans ça une
réponse générale à l'ensemble des
orateurs auraient moins d'intérêts mais
que chacun essaye de cibler ces
questions et ses réponses parce que on
en aura avec avec plaisir monsieur le
Président bon il y a beaucoup de sujets
donc en plus je vais les traiter de
manière énergétique on se donne jusqu'à
quelle heure monsieur le président
je suis juste pour ça je m'adapte au
gabarit
à vos ordres sur
ah mais au moins c'est carré
sur le monsieur sénateur sur le contrôle
parlementaire vous êtes sur du tous les
deux je pense que c'est clé dès lors
qu'on s'accorde sur le respect du secret
derrière je pense qu'il faut tout
assumer et tout ce que l'on peut faire
doit être fait
sur la réserve si des questions et de
fait le débat l'assemblée n'a pas permis
de tout purger tout traité mais si des
questions se posent sur les rythmes
montés en puissance la doctrine la
formation les équipements des
réservistes s'il faut préciser des
choses utiles moi je suis prêt à le
faire parce que c'est dans la copie donc
c'est tout simplement après une affaire
d'écriture ou de visibilité transparence
mais évidemment c'est dans la copie et
cela est déterminant ce que je pense que
c'est on peut parler de haute intensité
on peut pas parler d'engagement majeur
chez les autres sans avoir une réflexion
sur justement la part des réservistes et
le rôle des réservistes dans le modèle
d'armée globale c'est un point clé OPEX
compris et on a parlé cette nuit de de
beaucoup d'Afrique et je vous en
remercie
on voit bien que sur les missions de
formation pour les partenaires nos
réservistes quand vous êtes lieutenant
colonel et vous êtes retraités de
l'armée vous êtes réserviste il est
évident que vous avez encore des choses
à apporter notamment sur ces fonctions
là donc je pense que là pour le coup le
sujet réserve s'il faut le détourer
mieux on le fera sans dare F5 pour
répondre au sénateurs Perrin c'est
complètement dans la LPM j'ai présidé un
CMI il y a maintenant quelques semaines
qui permet de lancer justement le
standard 5 ça veut dire que l'ensemble
des sommes pour les études et la
faisabilité et dans la LPM que je
défends devant vous cet après-midi que
ça emporte évidemment le neuron et que
ça nous permet pour 2030 d'avoir
évidemment
la mise en service au début de la LPM
suivante qui est un point clé parce que
certains ont voulu opposer le standard
F5 et le Scaff mais je rappelle qu'on
n'est pas dans la même temporalités et
qu'ensuite il aura une cohabitation si
j'ose dire entre les deux le SCAP c'est
vraiment pour vraiment longtemps post 40
et donc pour le coup c'est notre
responsabilité politique de faire le
standard F5 parce que c'est évidemment
la suite logique et pas que pour
nous-mêmes j'ai la faiblesse de penser
qu'à l'export 5 aussi doit trouver
évidemment ça c'est partenaires dans une
fidélité autour du club rafale scorpion
capacité industrielle à livrer alors oui
enfin ça dépend quoi la capacité à
livrer du Griffon n'est pas complètement
la même que celle du jaguar s'il fallait
dire les choses mais je le redis
cohérence plutôt que masse c'est bien de
faire de livres un griffon derrière il
faut quand même que le SID vous
construise le parking et le nouveau
hangar qui va avec le griffon il faut
qu'on soit capable d'avoir les munitions
qui vont avec les pièces détachées le
MCO bref on rien la cohérence ça c'est
clé et je pense que celles et ceux qui
sont allés sur Orion ont vu que
lorsqu'on repassait par brigade et
division ce qui était très important
c'est d'avoir une capacité à agir et non
pas une capacité à stocker
mon sale sujet et on fera un mauvais
cadeau aux armées mon avis que
d'envisager ce sujet différemment
j'espère que les auditions que vous avez
menées avec les différents chefs majeurs
voulant enfin complètement démontrer
après je serai
[Musique]
on va regarder la question des drones
sans un miroir regardez aussi les
capacités souveraines en matière de
lutte antidrone donc toute cette famille
là pour le coup elle est intéressante
parce que elle participe à la
transformation de notre modèle d'armée à
la prise en muscle de notre BTD donc si
vous estimez qu'il est nécessaire entre
le entre cette audition et pour moi
l'hémicycle puisque je serai pas en
commission pour les amendements que le
gouvernement produise des amendement du
Gouvernement pour venir compléter des
choses à votre demande sur le sujet moi
j'ai suivi complètement favorable après
c'est un débat que vous devez avoir
aussi sur la le niveau de bavardage ou
de taille du rapport annexé mais c'est
vous qui décidez voilà donc je peux pas
dire mieux en tout cas moi je suis
favorable à ce qu'on fasse transparence
je trouve aussi que c'est bien parce que
ça permettra aussi la lisibilité de la
LPM à l'avenir sur ce que législateur et
le gouvernement du moment aura voulu
assigner comme moyen autant aux armées
qu'elle a des Géa qu'à la BITD donc il y
a aussi une dimension saine et pas que
dire il y a 5 milliards pour les drones
après c'est une affaire d'épaisseur du
rapport annexé en tout cas moi j'y suis
j'y suis assez favorable financement
Ukraine
c'est clé
c'est clé parce que la méthode qu'on a
qu'on a retenu je leur dis pas je
l'avais longuement détaillé lors de la
dernière audition elle est performante
parce qu'elle permet pas abîmer le
modèle d'armée après je regarde le
sénateur de neige
faut pas non plus qu'on se monte c'est
un coup pour le contribuable
quand on dit or LPM c'est pas hors
budget de l'État
et ça peut-être que dans un format dédié
monsieur le Président il faudra aussi
que le moment venu je rééclaire aussi
quand même peut-être l'Assemblée
nationale Sénat sur le fait que si ce ne
sont pas des dépenses dans notre
programmation militaire ce sont quand
même des dépenses militaires pour aider
un partenaire et un allié en guerre et
c'est quand même l'argent du
contribuable et que nul ne sait combien
de temps ces guerres peut durer et que
cela commence évidemment à constituer
des sommes qui sont importantes pour les
finances publiques je pense que c'est
notre devoir de le faire mais je pense
que voilà je le dis parce que j'étais
frappé de certaines commentaires de
parlementaires pour être honnête avec
vous de dire oui c'est hors LPM
notamment quand on avait le débat sur
les marches pour être transparent oui
c'est hors LPM donc en fait ça compte
pas non ça compte ça compte pour le
budget de l'État et plus ça durera plus
ça va compter
et donc en fait dans l'agrégat y compris
de la programmation militaire j'en dis
pas plus mais enfin faut regarder ce qui
n'est pas visible à côté soit parce que
c'est discret soit parce que ça n'a pas
lieu d'être montré dans la programmation
militaire parce que l'Ukraine a été
sorti la programmation militaire mais en
même temps que les marches vous avez
quand même d'autres sommes qui sont
engagées par l'État pour aider nos amis
ukrainiens et je pense que vous qui sera
amené à examiner le programmation de
finance publique et autres exercices du
même type dans les semaines et moi qui
viendront la question de la d'Ukraine
fait quand même partie de l'équation à
un moment donné en tout cas je ne
saurais la soirée l'occulté ça je pense
que c'est un point important que je vous
demanderai d'ailleurs d'intégrer dans
vos réflexions sur les marches et
regardez l'agrégat dépense militaires de
manière globale même s'il est hors LPM
pourraient tout à fait directe et clair
monsieur
d'être parti de la menace
alors qui est un peu de frustration
autour de la RNS etc je peux l'entendre
après j'ai toujours tenté dans mes
auditions ici quand même de commencer
toujours par ça quand j'avais fait mon
schéma sur la voûte nucléaire qu'est ce
qui peut passer sous la voûte nucléaire
le risque cyber les fonds marins le
spatial etc je l'ai fait à dessin
j'espère que les chefs d'état-major
l'ont fait aussi devant vous parce que
c'est le but des auditions qu'il doit
faire devant vous après moi je me remets
au président Cambon s'il faut encore
faire autrement je suis prêt à le faire
mais je pense que dans des auditions qui
ne seraient pas retransmis on peut aller
plus loin pour être transparent avec
vous monsieur le Center mal voilà je le
dis sur quels sont les cas pratiques
sécuritaires qu'on redoute quels sont je
donnerai aucun pays ici dans ce format
mais quels sont les quatre de figures de
déstabilisation de pays plus ou moins
proches de la France qui pourrait
engager nos armées à horizon de 5 ou 10
ans je pense moi je suis prêt à le faire
mais dans quelque chose qui est par
transmis pour être clair avec vous mais
je pense que c'est utile parce que ça
permet de comprendre tout ce qui ne se
voit pas dans la LPM
et en fait c'est là où je fais confiance
beaucoup quand même de militaires est la
meilleure dans sa fonctionne c'est qu'en
fait on est reparti comme un beaucoup de
ces cas pratiques là soit parce qu'ils
sont existants et qu'on avait pris du
retard
sur le classique soit parce qu'il
correspondent à des sauts technologiques
nouveaux et d'ailleurs je suis étonné de
voir que parfois ces questions là n'ont
pas forcément fait l'objet de
suffisamment de débats or ce sont les
points historiques moi je vais pas me
battre sur le mot historique de toute
façon c'est l'histoire qui est
historique ou pas là où je suis attaché
ce mot transformation parce qu'en fait
il y aura un avant et après en matière
spatiale en matière de guerre des mines
par exemple ou en matière de cyber c'est
incontestable ce que j'ai indiqué à la
DR sur les missions que la DGSE va se
voir confier sur sur cette affaire votre
voisin ou le présent comme vous pourrez
revenir donc ça je peux évidemment y
revenir devant vous autant qu'il le
faudra mais il est clair que les
contrats opérationnels
sont satisfaits dans le cadre de cette
loi de programmation militaire et que
pour le coup si vous revenez au
cadencement j'ai tenu pour le coup par
honnêteté compris ceux qui nous
succéderont que 2027 soit le point de
passage important en la matière quand on
dit par exemple logique divisionnaire ou
brigade pour l'armée de terre être
capable de rejeter un modèle constitué
Obs cohérent de combat soit dans un
format autant nationale soit dans un
format hors temple quand vous savez le
faire seul vous savez le faire aussi en
dehors de l'OTAN pour d'autres missions
expéditionnelles un peu type pour le
coup c'est 2027 que nous avons retenu
comme date considérant président de la
République souhaitait pouvoir donner à
son successeur chef des armées quelles
qu'ils soient des capacités
opérationnelles qui fonctionnent après
la vie organique elle continuera elle
continuera de façon après 2030 et après
2035 et ça pour le coup depuis 1960 donc
voilà et vous avez raison de citer le
président Mitterrand ou d'ailleurs si on
était encore plus complet et plus
honnête jusqu'à Pierre Mendès France
pour citer un élu du département de
l'Eure puisque par exemple on sait très
bien aussi que c'est la quatrième
République qui a permis de semer
quelques germes qui ont permis de faire
la dissuasion nucléaire dans les années
60 et je l'ai dit à l'Assemblée parce
que pour le coup on considère qu'il faut
pas pas de révisionnisme historique il
faut être fort rendre à chacun de ces
responsables politiques ce qu'ils ont pu
faire et nous autres ne nous en montrer
à la hauteur le rôle de la France de
l'OTAN c'est un vrai sujet
j'ai envie de dire tant de pays tant de
guerre
en dissuasion comme en planification
sur terre et dans les mers parce que le
volet maritime est trop souvent écarté
je le disais en introduction et cette
nuit donc ça il faut le faire et puis
sur les missions qui sont confiées
évidemment la question de l'Afrique je
pense qu'on a commencé votre groupe a
demandé ce débat cette nuit
dans un hémicycle comble
j'estime qu'il faut qu'on continue le
débat parce que pour le coup il est clé
les capacités expéditionnelles que l'on
souhaite voir confier aux armées en
fonction des missions et je l'ai dit
2000 2010 de l'interposition plutôt une
usien 2010 maintenant plutôt une culture
expéditionnelle de lutte contre le
terreau c'est pas complètement le même
métier militaire en ce moment on le voit
bien c'est plutôt du rezevac mise en
protection de population Sagittaire ou
Soudan c'est encore un autre métier et
en fait c'est ce que je veux vraiment
essayer de de faire de bonnes foi avec
les uns et les autres c'est de repartir
de cas pratique comme cela en mode
est-ce qu'on est capable de le faire si
oui sous quel préavis est-ce qu'on est
capable de le faire seul et combien de
temps on est capable de tenir tout seul
je pense qu'à chaque fois c'est comme ça
qu'il faut qu'on se pose les questions
et ça permet de mieux comprendre aussi
comment on a construit le modèle arme et
ça explique que si ce pourquoi bah vaut
mieux décaler quelques griffons sur la
période à venir parce que ce qui compte
c'est une fois de plus avoir de brigade
une division ou des capacités
expéditionnelles en tout cas je pourrais
à chaque fois que justifier devant vous
pendant les débats et à chaque
amendement vous dire aussi comment ça a
été construit après je vous aurais
convaincu ou non mais en tout cas il y
aura une réponse à chacune des questions
qui pourront être posées en la matière
économie de guerre la France n'est pas
en guerre vous avez raison de le
rappeler parce que ça permet aussi de
contrer un certain nombre de narratif
qu'on peut entendre ici ou là pourquoi
le président de la République avait
employé cette expression parce que il
s'agit des dépour nous un allié en
guerre et en fait non mais quand il a
dit économie de guerre il faut redonner
le contexte après on peut ne pas être
d'accord mais je redonne le contexte
c'était le moment dans lequel fallait
aider l'Ukraine c'est le moment où
d'ailleurs vous les parlementaires vous
nous mettiez la pression en mode mais
vous faites des sessions d'armes à
l'Ukraine mais qui va l'air compléter
est-ce que ça va aller vite etc et c'est
là où le président a dit il faut
basculer dans une économie de guerre non
pas parce que la France est en guerre
mais parce que notre BITD a aussi
vocation à aider des pays en guerre soit
parce qu'ils sont nos alliés
soit parce que je ne désespère pas aussi
qu'on vende des armes et donc par
définition pour être crédible il faut
être capable de basculer dans une
économie de guerre même si c'est pas
pour nous je justifie pas l'expression
mais je redonne son contexte d'emploi et
de fait nous sommes engagés dans une
économie industrielle de défense de
guerre pour un pays à lié en guerre et
sur lequel chaque semaine ça me donne du
souci pour faire en sorte qu'on soit
capable de délivrer et livrer des obus
en quantité suffisante suffisamment à
temps pour nos amis Ukrainiens pareil
pour la défense solaire pareil pour les
équipements terrestres et ça c'est quand
même quelque chose qui nous inquiète
beaucoup parce que si on n'est pas
capable de le faire pour l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui je peux vous conseille
capable de le faire pour la France
demain et pour le coup c'est un des
nœuds de la transformation me
semble-t-il après que l'expression
puisse faire le départ je l'entends 413
milliards alors sur les efforts
au fond
il ira l'approche peut-être politique de
cette affaire je me déclare incompétent
sur les aspects plus budgétaires et plus
militaires
déjà militaire j'en ai fait la
démonstration devant vous vous avez
quand même des bosses qui correspondent
à des besoins en physique
et on crédit de paiement ça c'est
factuel votre porte-avion vous pouvez
faire une marche à 10 milliards d'euros
de l'année 2024 votre p.a NG sortira pas
plus vite des Chantiers de l'Atlantique
or là le sénateur de neige m'en voudrai
on se retrouverait donc à avoir des AE
qui ne se soldent pas par des CP et on
ballerait pardon cette expression de
triviale des CP pendant 5 ou 10 ans
parce qu'on aurait fait gonfler le
budget des armées virtuellement pour des
besoins physiques parce que le crédit de
paiement je vous rappelle c'est comme
dans nos mairies c'est au moment où le
physique arrive bon ça c'est une réalité
ce qui est vrai pour le porte-avion
c'est vrai pour toute la classe
Barracuda suffrain c'est vrai pour
l'ensemble des CNLE c'est vrai pour une
partie des programmes spatiaux si vous
commencez à les regarder dans le détail
sans compter ce qui est complètement
classifié sur la dissuasion vous avez
compris de quoi il s'agit bah en fait
quoi qu'il arrive et ça je le dis pour
le la mémoire des débats parlementaires
parce que vous l'avez dit mais
n'effrayez pas la sénatrice Duranton
peut-être qu'un jour je redeviendrai
sénateur mais il en a profité pour le
dire pendant que vous discutiez mais
c'est la triste
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que et
ça je c'est ma bonne foi je le dis et je
si je suis sénateur je poserai la
question à celle de celui qui me
succédera
quoi qu'il arrive quel que soit le
vainqueur de l'élection présidentielle
en 2027 et quel que soit l'identité du
ministre des Armées entre les années
2028 et 2034 vous avez des boss
physiques capacités
quelque part parce que tous celles et
ceux qui vous diront le contraire à ce
moment-là ça sera faux tout simplement
parce que tous les vins au 25 ans vous
avez d'énormes besoins de remise à
niveau la dissuasion nucléaire que la
dissuasion d'aujourd'hui est plutôt
celle de Jacques Chirac et Nicolas
Sarkozy pour faire très vite et que
globalement sur la mondialisation des
missiles dans la composante aéroportée
pour les forces à une stratégiques pour
les SN2 etc vous avez plusieurs années
dans lequel parlons de cette expression
il faudra cracher des crédits de
paiement quoi qu'il arrive donc ça c'est
ça ça s'impose
on commencera et la prochaine avec
on commence pardonnez-moi sur on
commence à être dans la bosse et ça
continue et ça pour le coup c'est
évidemment dans la trajectoire mais ça
c'est vos crédits physiques c'est ce que
vous dit soit l'industriel soit la DGA
soit pour être plus précis la direction
des applications militaires du CEA qui
vous dit bah voilà pour telle ou tel
programme lié à la dissuasion par
exemple donc j'en dis un peu plus que ce
que j'en dis d'habitude
mon galandra après enfin globalement
vous avez une chronique année par année
qui fixe un certain nombre de besoins
qui tient à tout un tas de sujets que
vous pouvez imaginer par ailleurs donc
ça je le dis parce que c'est important
quand même que le Sénat en soit informé
instruit mais j'ai envie de dire vous
quand vous étiez mère les uns et les
autres et que vous votez une piscine au
conseil municipal avec vos apcp c'est
pas parce que vous avez voté la piscine
que pour autant ça se traduit en crédit
de paiement pour payer la piscine donc
c'est le moment où véritablement vous
avez les travaux de la piscine qui
démarrent sur plusieurs années qu'il
faut sortir les crédits de paiement et
si on vous dit même monsieur le Maire
faut mettre tout l'argent dans l'année
prochaine tout de suite on va dire bah
non parce que de toute façon c'est pas
les années dans lequel la piscine sera
livrée donc je ne pourrais pas sortir
des crédit de paiement donc je ne dis
pas que ma diffusion nucléaire c'est une
piscine municipale mais globalement les
principes budgétaires étant les mêmes il
y a beaucoup de choses qui s'imposent à
la morphologie de la construction des
marches ce qui veut dire aussi que j'ai
par exemple
tout des amendements qui visaient à
avoir des marches qui étaient parfois
ridicules entre 29 et 30 étaient des
amendements irréalistes sauf
approvisionner beaucoup d'argent début
de période ne pas les dépenser et
reporter des CP de manière infinie donc
ça il y a je pourrais aussi revenir
autant qu'il le faudra il y a quand même
des réalités physiques ensuite les
marges on dit souvent ce sont les mêmes
marches sous-entendus c'est la même
somme non ça faut pour le coup faut pas
qu'on faut pas qu'on induise en erreur
nos nos concitoyens non mais je le ça se
dit beaucoup maintenant à l'extérieur je
le dis déjà dans un escalier si vous
marchez toujours sur la même marge
globalement vous montez pas l'escalier
c'est à dire que vous marchez sur la
marche suivante donc à chaque fois c'est
3 milliards de plus avec un effort qui
s'accumule et qui s'additionne non mais
je le redis parce que la confusion a été
entretenue par certains et donc je pense
que c'est important vous reprenez les
mêmes sommes non on additionne la même
taille d'augmentation à la simple global
en fait quand on le dit comme ça tout
d'un coup ça fait drôle parce que ça
faisait une marche à 1,8 milliards en
2018 puis petit à petit on s'aperçoit
qu'on est en 2023 et qu'en fait on est
sur une marche à 11,6 milliards nous qui
sommes respectueux de l'argent public
dans cette maison
c'est quand même de l'argent en 24 14,7
milliards en 25 17,7 milliards en 2026
20,7 milliards en 2027 termes du mandat
présidentiel c'est factuel ça sera quand
même une marge de
23,7 milliards d'euros en 10 ans dire
que l'essentiel de l'effort se fait
après c'est pas vrai il y a deux tiers
qui se fait dans les 10 ans et un tiers
ensuite alors après on peut toujours
discuter de ça mais il faut être précis
comme toi faire là et on arrive à une
marche de on arrive à une marge 36
milliards d'euros 36,6 milliards d'euros
en 2030 qui correspond aussi bien sûr à
l'ensemble du
qui pardon
c'est logique enfin ou alors faut faire
des LPM sur 15 ans et puis sur 50 on
peut pas remettre en cause les règles de
fait ou alors il faut pas dlpm qui est
engendre ce que tu es un présidentiel ça
ne s'est jamais vu depuis 1960 il y a
toujours eu de l'autre programmation
militaire qui parfois enjambait une
élection présidentielle si j'étais
taquin je crois même que le général de
Gaulle le voulait pour contraindre son
prédécesseur Georges Pompidou a accepté
les dépenses militaires bon ça c'est ce
que disent les mémoires
je crois aussi et François Mitterrand
lui-même n'a rien remis en cause donc ça
tombe bien et
mes deux ans de moins là aussi
l'argument est rhétorique ça veut donc
dire que avec l'Ukraine il fallait
paramètres une loi de programmation
militaire en urgence sur la table ça
veut dire par exemple la revalorisation
des grilles indiciaires pour nos soldats
il fallait les décaler
si mais si la loi programmation
militaire ce n'est pas que d'une courbe
avec des marches ce sont aussi les
objectifs que nous assignons en face
moi je suis c'est contraire c'est
contraire à ce que c'est contraire à ce
que vous dites par ailleurs sur le
contrôle du Parlement si le gouvernement
commence à de fait je prends pour un
acquis là monsieur le sénateur fait mal
ça veut donc dire le programmation
militaire c'est prendre beaucoup de
choses qui sont du domaine de l'exécutif
et du réglementaire et de le basculer
dans la loi de programme pour permettre
au Parlement de le décider
pardon les grilles indiciaires c'est pas
du législatif
d'acheter tel ou tel équipement j'en
fais exprès d'acheter tel ou tel
équipement ce n'est pas du législatif
donc si on n'avait pas remis d'un côté
il y a pas eu de vote en 2000 22 et 1 et
vous nous le reprochez et j'en ai pris
acte et de l'autre côté quand le
président de la République dit avec
l'Ukraine et le renouvellement de mon
mandat je veux redémarrer avec une
nouvelle LPM vous me dites mais pourquoi
on aurait pu attendre ce sont les mêmes
marches bon j'ai pas compris alors
en tout cas étaler la discussion là en
tout cas il faut qu'on consente les
réponses parce que moi j'ai une liste
impressionnante et bien je me tais non
non non c'est pas ce que je veux dire
non c'est pas mais il faut qu'on arrive
à
voilà alors on va pas on va on va
prendre deux autres présentes dans des
groupes pour l'Union centriste Olivier
sigoletti
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre notre groupe est conscient des
efforts consentis par la nation au
profit de nos armées je reprendrai
simplement trois chiffres de cet LPM
notamment dans le programme 178
69 milliards d'euros bénéficieront à
l'entraînement et à l'activité des
forces 49 milliards d'euros seront
alloués à l'entretien programmé du
matériel et 18 milliards d'euros
serviront pour les différents services
de soutien
ce ministre nous ne pouvons que que nous
réjouir de la discussion que nous avons
eu dans votre propre éliminaire
concernant la DT la DTO et les contrats
opérationnels ça fait partie de du débat
que nous avons eu ce matin en commission
et autant nous pouvons comprendre
et souscrire au fait que sur la
dissuasion il n'est pas souhaitable de
communiquer un certain nombre
d'indicateurs un certain nombre
d'éléments autant il nous paraît
nécessaire et opportun d'obtenir des
éléments qui ne sont pas classifiés
protégés en diffusion rest sur des
équipements moins sensibles et je
reviens sur l'entretien programmé du
matériel nous avons besoin nous
parlementaires d'avoir
les annuités concernant le PM pour
suivre les contrats opérationnels et
nous avons besoin monsieur le ministre
comme vous l'avez indiqué de continuer à
bénéficier des indicateurs en matière de
DTO c'est important pour les rapporteurs
du programme 178 mais aussi pour les
autres programmes et je crois que nous
avons besoin d'avoir cet échange nous
avons besoin de construire quelque chose
qui permettent au parlementaire
d'assumer leur mission sans toutefois
révéler au grand public et
éventuellement à des compétiteurs qui ne
nous souhaiteraient pas forcément qui
nous aurait qui n'auraient pas une
totale bienveillance envers la nation
des éléments stratégiques ou sensibles
un mot concernant le PNG nous ne pouvons
que nous réjouir de cette validation du
programme
sur le ministre je vous renvoie à
l'excellent rapport que nous avions fait
que mon collègue Gilbert Roger dans
lequel nous avions prévu de la
définition de ce de ce PNG mais je vois
qu'il s'arrête dans sa progression vers
la sortie nous avions défini
effectivement un PNG qui est celui qui a
été qui a été validé nous avions aussi
envisagé la prolongation éventuelle du
Charles de Gaulle mais nous n'en avons
nous n'avions en aucun cas envisager la
construction d'un deuxième PNG je crois
qu'il serait déraisonnable en tout cas
pour nous que l'on soit dans cette
démarche contenue de la dette
conséquente que nous allons laisser aux
générations à venir
un mot monsieur le ministre concernant
la cohérence je crois que nous avons
aujourd'hui un peu de mal à comprendre
comment nous allons passer de la
surdisponibilité
à l'éventuelle sur usure du matériel et
je crois que nous étions dans la NPM
précédente avec des programmes
conséquents je pense au programme
scorpion notamment dont la cible a été
décalée dans cet LPM notre inquiétude
porte sur la surusure du capital
technique de nos armées cette question a
certainement été prise en compte est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des détails
comment est-ce que l'on a calculé cette
cette cible et cette question pour
savoir quelle est quelles sont les
arbitrages qui font paraître rentables
une sur-utilisation des matériels avec
un coût inévitablement en matière de PM
donc je crois que pour nous c'est une
c'est une inquiétude d'avoir à la fois
cette disponibilité technique des
matériels sans engendrer une sur usure
et donc un surcoût en matière
d'entretien programmé du matériel voilà
merci monsieur le ministre
merci Olivier donc la parole pour le
groupe rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant à François
Patriat merci monsieur le Président je
vais vous faire gagner un petit peu de
temps parce que d'abord féliciter le
ministre pour son propos réitérer après
trois parutions de lancer de commission
à la fois précis pas toujours consiste
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit c'est
ministre mais en tout cas mais en tout
cas répondant parfaitement à nos
questions
genre j'ai vu le débat aussi un peu je
regardais un peu le débat à l'Assemblée
il m'apparaît de bonne tenue tranchant
avec d'autres débats que je vois par
ailleurs en dehors de ce texte qui
aboutit un texte équilibré avec des
avancées et qui répond aux enjeux qui
étaient prévus dans la loi j'ai entendu
dans ensuite pour venir tout de suite à
l'audition j'ai entendu ce matin en
commission à la fois des inquiétudes et
des frustrations
j'ai le sentiment je me repose pas les
mêmes questions parce que c'est ici des
parlementaires beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus pertinents que moi sur les
questions précises mais j'ai le
sentiment que dans votre préambule vous
avez répondu à ce qui est le secret
défense il a discrétion ou l'avait
répondu sur la dissuasion et puis même
sur le contrôle parlementaire je note
que dans la loi qui est votée au
parlementaire il y a un article 7 7 bis
qui répond déjà au contrôle du Parlement
et un neuf qui répond aussi au contrôle
pour les forces outre-mer de notre force
outre-mer donc sur ce plan d'abord merci
ensuite je voudrais rappeler simplement
une chose c'est que le Président de la
République a engagé dès 2017 une
politique de rupture avec ce qui faisait
précédemment et je n'accuse personne
rassurez-vous parce que je n'étais pour
partie responsable aussi comme vous dans
le cadre de la LPM 2004 2030 il est il
est
bien sûr obligatoire que que la France
continue de renforcer ses moyens pour
trois raisons d'abord pour garantir son
autonomie stratégique ensuite pour
assurer ses engagements en tant
qu'alliés de l'OTAN et membre de l'Union
européenne et enfin pour être une
puissance d'équilibre et bon là ça a été
dit ça a été un peu commenté il s'agit
de passer d'une loi de réparation à une
loi de transformation pour nos capacités
de défense j'ai apprécié les réponses
que vous avez faites sur à la fois tout
ce qui était les détails contenants les
drones les questions qui ont été posées
de la souveraineté française à côté donc
moi j'ai pas de question particulière
simplement sur le financement j'ai cru
comprendre que tout le monde saluait
l'effort important qui est fait
très bien et qu'il y a des questions
après sur la mise en oeuvre ou sur les
détails mais je mettrai quand même en
garde ici mes collègues contre le fait
qu'il pourrait être fait plus parce que
plus c'est toujours plus je rappelle
quand même que actuellement la position
de la France de notation est quand même
menacée aujourd'hui que de faire plus
que de faire plus aujourd'hui pourrait
avoir des conséquences que chacun est
mis bien il imagine bien en termes de
taux d'intérêt donc j'appelle un peu mes
collègues ici ok à la critique à la
proposition et je sais qu'ils ont sont
capables avec beaucoup de talents mais
aussi un petit peu de raison pour que on
puisse tenir effectivement les
engagements qui sont pris et qui sont à
la hauteur d'un projet à la fois
efficace et équilibré moi je vous
remercie
allez vous voulez bien répondre monsieur
le ministre à ces deux interdits
le Président
je vais essayer de beaucoup plus concis
après c'est vrai que non mais après en
fait j'ai un côté j'essaie de bonne
élève quand une intervention d'un
parlementaire traite 7 ou 8 sujets je
note les 7 au vifs et j'essaie de
répondre de cette vie sujet donc vous
m'en voudrez donc pas si parfois je
choisis les sujets et que peut-être je
peux pas préparer écrire répondre mais
de fait quand les questions sont des
questions en râteau ça appelle donc une
longue réponse en râteau
monsieur le sénateur sigolite alors
dtdto merci d'être revenu je trouve ça
un point clé c'est un peu le corollaire
d'ailleurs de cohérence et masse au bout
d'un moment pendant des années aussi on
a on a drogué le Parlement parlant de
cette expression au seul tableau
capacitaire ce qui s'arrange bien les
industriels pour être très clair aussi
par ailleurs c'est la vie je peux
comprendre aussi pourquoi surtout que on
finit par l'oublier mais enfin jadis les
crédits diminués sérieusement et donc en
fait les armées essayez de garder la
cohérence avec un système qui se
repliait sur eux-mêmes bon et le risque
a été identifié c'est de perdre la
cohérence en crise de croissance
notamment avec aussi des lobbies
diverses et variés pour que tout le
monde achète aussi tout un tas de choses
sans se préoccuper de la crédibilité
militaire ou de l'affecter à des
contrats opérationnels concrets que l'on
peut donner aux armées et au mépris
aussi des nouveaux segments si on veut
faire la dernière armée dernier cri il y
a 15 ans c'est possible et on se dit
mais on fait pas de spatial on fait pas
de cyber etc on je le redis parce que le
décalage du capacitaire ce qui n'est pas
de l'annulation ça veut dire globalement
vous avez des sites qui vont tomber en
31 32 33
on le fait au nom de la cohérence aussi
parce qu'on se dit un griffon c'est bien
mais un griffon avec son parking et ses
pièces détachées comme je vous disais
c'est mieux puis à vrai dire c'est plus
large que ça j'espère qu'aurion a été
convaincant de ce point de vue c'est de
se dire mais une brigade ou une division
si derrière vous n'avez pas les frappes
dans la profondeur si derrière vous
n'avez pas la défense solaire qui va
autour si derrière il y a pas la lutte
antidrone de demain qui va autour c'est
le gros enjeux de nos amis Ukrainiens en
ce moment comment continuer à protéger
leur champ de bataille et les lignes de
front et en même temps les
infrastructures civiles et les villes en
matière de défense solaire c'est quelque
chose qui nous inspirer pour nous dans
quel que soit les contrats opérationnels
dans lequel on peut être engagé il y a
quelques bretons ici mais la guerre des
mines dans la capacité aussi à protéger
nos fonds sous-marins pour demain diluer
un sous-marin nucléaire ou la capacité
aussi à protéger nos fonds sous-marins
sur les câbles ou sur les holoducs ce
sont quand même des sujets qui sont
évidemment à traiter et donc au bout
d'un moment on revient aussi la
soutenabilité aussi de tout ça
et de tirer aussi des conclusions de
diffusion de nucléaire il y a des
menaces sur lequel on peut faire le pari
que
on les connaîtra pas parce que nous
avons la dissuasion ou alors c'est que
la diffusion de dissuète plus à ce
moment-là il faut aller jusqu'au bout du
débat ou alors c'est que nous n'avons
plus d'aliés alors faut aller jusqu'au
bout du débat donc en fait c'est ça
aussi que je cherche à réexpliquer à
chaque fois et c'est important parce que
la passion du tableau capacitaire ne
doit pas nous écarter des contrats
opérationnels tels qu'on les donne
vraiment alors après sur mesure du
capital capacitaire pour le coup sache
si vous voulez pour la séance pour elle
documenter mais en fait on est quand on
parle de décalage on est quand même sur
des arrivées massives
du Rafale en passant par les Griffons on
est quand même sur la LPM qui va
délivrer ce qui est très frustrant c'est
de se dire bah oui ce que vous avez voté
en 2018 prend autant de temps à arriver
mais ça c'est le sort de tous les
programmes militaires depuis le début de
l'aventure notre transformation des
années 60 et suivant donc il y a cette
inertie là est encore plus musulman sur
les grands programmes et vous avez cité
le PNG donc je n'y reviens pas mais de
fait il faut accepter aussi cette
temporalité là donc sur la
surutilisation non la vraie question
d'utilisation elle est sur le format non
pas organique mais hops hops c'est à
dire en clair une fois qu'on a deux
brigades une division pour l'armée de
terre pour 27 une disposition à faire
corde armée mais pas seule à plusieurs
un peu en bloc multiprise comme une
capacité à mener une grande coalition
navale autour du groupe Air en aval pour
prendre des exemples un peu différents
au fond c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
éprouver et le modèle de cohérence il
est là aussi en disant si vous avez la
tricion sur une brigade comment vous en
relevez une pour une autre et donc en
fait c'est là où moi je vous invite
aussi à faire des choix parce que sinon
c'est pas des marches ou des milliards
c'est un autre modèle qui n'est pas un
modèle français qu'on n'a jamais connu
d'ailleurs c'est de se dire bah en fait
on veut les États-Unis quoi
ça n'a jamais été l'objet donc après je
mais je veux pas qu'on laisse entendre
qu'on peut le faire j'ai encore entendu
des explications de vote et je sais
qu'elles étaient pour voter pour tout à
l'heure à l'Assemblée nationale mais qui
disait au fond tout ça n'est pas encore
assez etc enfin moi j'invite aussi à
regarder notre modèle l'armée on n'a
jamais voulu faire ça jamais depuis la
fin de guerre coloniale
au regard des menaces et des capacités
qui sont les nôtres je veux dire pour
quelle bataille pour quelle guerre
veut-on engager nos armées c'est ça le
juge de paix aussi quand même de la LPM
on peut pas dire qu'on soit non plus
assailli de recommandations ou de
contribution à la matière c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire donc voilà en tout cas
tout ça je pourrai on pourra le
documenter si vous le souhaitez c'est
important je pense que DTO c'est un
point clé et qui peut faciliter échanger
votre vie de rapporteur par ailleurs
donc moi je m'engage à revenir vers vous
sur cette affaire monsieur ministre
patria
bon sur la frustration
je n'étais pas là ce matin donc je ne
sais pas ce que vous avez ressenti mais
je vous connais donc si vous l'avez
ressenti c'est que c'est que c'est vrai
ou alors si c'est pas vrai ça vous
permettra d'être rassuré que dirons que
nous moi j'ai ressenti quand même dans
les débats politiques sur les questions
militaires un peu de frustration malgré
tout aussi
difficulté à donner acte que nous
remettons les moyens alors que pour
autant nous ne cherchons pas à être
remerciés moi la seule chose que je
demande c'est que on soit aussi dur avec
ce gouvernement que en tout cas qu'on ne
soit pas plus dur avec ce gouvernement
qui augmente les moyens pour nos armées
qu'à une certaine période dans lequel
lorsqu'il diminuait on n'était pas aussi
dur
voilà puisque je trouve que je suis
maire d'une ville qui a vu un
laboratoire fermé en 2008 de la DGA que
je suis maire d'une ville qui a vu un
régiment du Train fermé dans les années
90 je sais ce que c'est que dlpm dans
lequel les moyens diminuent et des
territoires qui pensent encore leur
plaît j'ai pas le souvenir à l'époque
que on était aussi dur sur les
ressources extra budgétaires ou les
marges frictionnelles avec les ministres
qui fermaient les régiments et bases
non mais je le dis je j'ai regardé comme
je mets les recettes extra budgétaires
d'une manière générale oui alors c'est
dommage parce que ce sont des recettes
en plus pour le ministère mais c'est pas
grave
encore faut-il savoir lesquels mais le
service de santé des armées je pense que
c'est c'est transparent est-ce que à ce
moment-là il faut aller jusqu'au bout
quand le ministère des armées vend du
patrimoine il faut plus que les sommes
revenaient au ministère des armées et
qui repasse par Bercy dans le budget
général de l'État tous les
parlementaires se sont toujours battus
contre ça jusqu'à présent
peut y revenir bon
service de santé des armées ils
accomplissent des actes médicaux qui
donneront à remboursement de l'Assurance
Maladie est-ce que ça repart dans le
budget global ou est-ce que ça affecte
au ministère des armées tout le
mouvement des discussions parlementaires
de ces 20 dernières années c'est de
l'affectation budgétaire au mépris du
principe d'un affectation par ailleurs
s'il faut y mettre fin ayant le débat ça
mettra mes successeurs en faiblesse dans
les discussions annuelles avec Bercy
c'est déjà écrit donc je ne le souhaite
pas c'est pour ça que je les défends
honnêtement j'ai voulu les montrer ces
ressources regrette en fait quand je
vois les débats que ça suscite quand ça
s'existant est cachée personne ne posait
de questions donc comme quoi ça va
parfois plus vite
ah vous savez j'ai beaucoup travaillé
pour ça non
mais il y a toujours eu des reports de
charges et toujours des marges
fictionnelles on pourra y revenir y
compris quand d'autres gouvernements
faisaient des LPM avec des budgets qui
diminuaient je le dis parce que c'est
important quand même de le dire je ne
j'accepte des challenger vous le savez
et d'être contredit mais comme le
ministre Patriat tendu la perche de la
frustration moi-même je l'ai prise parce
que je pense qu'il faut le dire faire
plus on peut toujours faire plus
je pense que faire mieux ça compte
beaucoup d'en faire plus je pense qu'il
faut se poser la question aussi de la
soutenabilité parce que avant les
objectifs étaient généreux mais
l'exécution ne se faisait pas le retrait
ça veut dire que désormais aussi quand
on fixe des objectifs il faut s'assurer
de la soutenabilité parce qu'il en va de
notre crédibilité bon je le dis quand
même parce que
après c'est peut-être le prix du grand
pardon parce que les crédits ont
beaucoup diminué dans le passé que de
vouloir désormais les ré-augmenter très
très vite mais en tout cas je pense
qu'il faut aussi le faire évidemment
avec une progressivité c'est ce que je
crois c'est ce que je pense
dernier point je le redis quand même
pour la cohérence pour le Sénat sur les
finances publiques
l'aide à l'Ukraine pèse elle existe elle
est là je le dis parce que elle est en
dehors des 413 milliards mais elle
représente de l'argent pour le
contribuable et qu'on ne peut pas le
balayer d'un revers de main voilà en
réponse aux deux interlocuteurs et des
intervenants ou de parlementaires
merci Monsieur vinis les deux suivants
le pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste pierre leur rend puis
après les indépendants Républiques et
territoires ce sera ah non il est pas là
on passera andriol pour le Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen allons-y
merci monsieur le Président oui monsieur
le ministre
bon il y a déjà maintenant plusieurs
semaines que nous sommes dans ce
déballage débat important a eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale et j'espère en
tout cas nous y contribuerons que ce
débat se poursuive au fond pendant les
débats de la LPM au Sénat parce que je
j'ai le sentiment que malgré toutes les
explications que vous donnez il demeure
beaucoup d'interrogations sur les
concepts et les priorités stratégiques
de cette LPM alors
et le fait que nous n'ayons pas eu
un débat
stratégique approfondie sur la revue
nationale stratégique et encore moins de
débat autour d'un livre blanc puisqu'il
n'y en a pas eu que précédemment nous
n'ayons pas eu de débat d'actualisation
de la LPM tout ça va planer sur le débat
de la LPM parce qu'on va être obligé
d'avoir au fur et à mesure d'une de ce
débat des débats stratégiques qu'il
aurait mérité qui aurait mérité cette ce
débat en amont alors il y en a qui sont
de nature très globaux notamment ce
concept qui consiste à dire
répéter un peu maintenant comme un
mantra si tu veux la paix prépare la
guerre c'est quand même une idée
qui mériterait
qui mériterait beaucoup de débats en soi
je pense qu'elle est très discutable
dans le monde dans lequel on vit
mais ensuite évidemment cette question
se décline dans beaucoup de dans
beaucoup de questions donc je pense que
l'absence de débat sérieux on a monte
sur la nature de la conflictualité
mondiale sur la nature des menaces sur
leur cause sur la manière de prévenir
ces menaces
aujourd'hui demain à l'avenir tout ça
évidemment va nous manquer pour avoir un
débat plus éclairé ou en tout cas va
constituer
constitue parfois des non-dits et
j'espère que nous les lèverons que nous
les lèverons dans le débat au moins pour
éclairer le choix politique que nous
ferons les uns et les autres et que et
le choix des le choix des Français en
tout cas l'information des Français
parce que c'est ma deuxième remarque on
va quand même mettre beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup d'argent
413 milliards c'est beaucoup
maintenant on sait que les 413 milliards
sont sanctuarisés puisque la question
qui persistait sur les recettes enfin
sur les moyens extra budgétaires a été
levés par un amendement qui a été adopté
à l'Assemblée plus ce que nous dépensons
en ce moment pour l'Ukraine plus le fait
qu'il a été ajouté dans le LPM qui
s'agit d'un minimum
ces sommes sont en temps comme un
minimum je crois que c'est ça la phrase
donc ça veut dire que d'ores et déjà on
ouvre la porte à plus
donc ça fait ça fait beaucoup d'argent
et il faut donc bien s'expliquer
publiquement et avec les Français sur Le
sur ce que nous allons faire de ces
sommes considérables donc d'un moment où
il manque aussi beaucoup d'argent pour
d'autres enjeux qui d'ailleurs pour
certains ont avoir directement avec la
question de l'insécurité mondiale par
exemple le réchauffement climatique
et il y a beaucoup d'autres domaines
notamment celui que je viens de citer
qui mériterait des lois de programmation
que nous n'avons pas
alors nous nous allons poser un certain
nombre de questions dans ce débat nous
en poserons à nouveau sur la dissuasion
il y a une histoire français une
histoire à la position des communistes
français vous avez évoqué plusieurs fois
c'est une histoire française
singulièrement française je vous ai
entendu je sais plus où faire une
référence à l'Union soviétique à propos
de ce débat
l'histoire des du rapport des
communistes au nucléaire est une
histoire profondément française à la
Libération avec le général de Gaulle
ceux qui inventent parmi les ceux qui
inventent l'énergie nucléaire il y a de
grands scientifiques français au premier
rang desquels Frédéric Joliot-Curie
qui va contribuer à créer le CEA dont il
sera d'ailleurs
banni quelques années plus tard au
moment de la guerre froide et c'est
grands scientifiques français qui sont
font partie des créateurs disent dès le
départ qu'ils sont opposés à
l'utilisation militaire de cette énergie
qu'ils sont favorables à son utilisation
civile opposée à son utilisation
militaire et ils vont se mobiliser
pendant longtemps et les communistes
avec eux contre la constitution des
arsenaux nucléaires que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
de tous les arceaux nucléaires donc
c'est pour ça que je dis que la
référence il n'y a pas des communistes
qui étaient pour la bombe pour la bombe
soviétique et contre la bombe américaine
les communistes leur position de fond
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est que la seule
perspective historique raisonnable et
celle de l'élimination des armes
nucléaires de toutes les armes
nucléaires
ensuite effectivement dans les années 70
les communistes prenant acte
de l'état de la question
on se sont ralliés à la
présence d'une dissuasion nucléaire
française mais en disant deux choses dès
ce moment-là strict suffisance et
poursuit de l'effort de
d'élimination de ces armes
d'où le débat sur le tion et le TNP Vous
vous opposez les deux nous nous opposons
pas les deux
et d'ailleurs le TNP est en panne
l'article 6 du TNP n'est pas appliqué
aujourd'hui
pas appliquer concrètement
donc nous avons besoin de relancer ces
efforts là et sur la stricte suffisance
effectivement c'est là-dessus que nous
poserons des questions pour savoir si
les crédits nous allons engager et qui
vont fortement augmenté que vous venez
de le redire à l'instant
se justifie au nom de la stricte
suffisance de ces de ces arsenaux donc
sur ça effectivement je crois que nous
aurons besoin d'avoir le débat et puis
nous aurons besoin d'avoir ce débat
parce que évidemment le niveau puisque
ça va fortement augmenter ça pèse sur le
reste
donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions sur le modèle d'armée que nous
sommes en train de dessiner avec la LPM
c'est que quand le président de la
République a parlé d'économie de guerre
à parler de haute intensité
à annoncer 413 milliards je crois que
beaucoup de de nos collègues
s'attendaient à ce que à la fois nous
poursuivions la dissuasion et que nous
ayons un équipement de nos forces bien
supérieures à ce qu'il découvre
finalement
et au fur et à mesure que nous entrons
dans le dans le détail nous nous
apercevons nous allons avoir une
dissuasion modernisée avec un très fort
investissement dans cette modernisation
et un équipement d'efforts qui sera qui
est étalé qui qui n'est pas celui
attendu par certains mais qui finalement
conduit à quoi
a une question stratégique que nous
devons discuter nous allons avoir des
forces qui resteront principalement des
forces de projection
évidemment ça ne sera pas des forces de
projection ou celle de celle que nous
utilisons dans les Opex pour aller
faire des interventions militaires en
Afrique mais les forces dont nous
disposerons sont des forces
dimensionnées pour s'inscrire dans des
guerres à l'extérieur de nos frontières
pas pour défendre notre territoire dans
le cadre
de l'OTAN jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est ça qui doit être discuté c'est à
dire le format des forces que nous
allons auxquelles nous allons c'est pas
seulement de dire bon ils en prouve
peut-être un peu moins mais mieux équipé
etc que trop qui fonctionne pas bien
c'est pourquoi faire
pour aller faire la guerre ou avec qui
et pour quels objectifs et cette
question là pour le moment je trouve
qu'elle n'est pas débattue ou qu'elle
n'est pas débattue en toute en toute
clarté et nous devons l'éclairer et puis
pour terminer je citerai juste à la
volée juste qu'elle quelques
questions je pense que sur la question
des espaces communs il y a une question
transversale
c'est la question de la souveraineté
numérique
le
patron d'assaut qui était que nous
auditionnons il y a quelques temps à
beaucoup insisté sur la question du
cloud souverain
et je pense que cette question dans la
priorité de la construction de notre
souveraineté numérique n'est peut-être
pas traité suffisamment à la hauteur on
peut protéger les câbles sous-marins
mais on peut aussi se poser des
questions sur la territorialisation de
nos centres de données sur nos cloud
souverains en matière numérique qui sont
aussi
aussi importantes et tout ça nous
renvoie à des questions sur l'abbé TD
que j'ai pas le temps de développer
quant aux bases puisque vous avez fait
un référence à ce que j'ai dit hier je
pense que mon déposera des amendements
sur certains alors on aura l'occasion de
poursuivre le débat effectivement par
rapport à la réponse que moi est fait
hier la question c'est de savoir quel
partenariat de sécurité et de défense
nous voulons construire demain avec des
pays africains souverains
et nous nous sommes prêts à voir ce
déballage je ne pense pas que les bases
telles qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
répondent à cette correctement à cette
question donc nous nous poursuivrons ce
débat de manière plus éclairée qu'avec
la avec ce que nous nous sommes dit
brièvement hier soir
il nous reste deux intervenants mais
après des questions qui sont rapides de
telle sorte qu'on ne termine pas la
séance à 5 comme ça arrive parfois allez
andriol
merci président monsieur le ministre
depuis plusieurs semaines nous examinons
en commission les contours de la future
loi de programmation militaire sous
l'éclairage expert de nos collègues
rapporteurs
la majorité d'entre nous s'accorde à
dire que l'effort de 413 milliards
d'euros prévu pour à partir 2024 sur ces
temps et conséquent même si on peut
discuter les bornes qui ont été évoquées
il est en tout cas nécessaire et
bienvenue compte tenu du Lot contexte
géopolitique nous connaissons donc bien
sûr le conflit qui se joue en Ukraine
aux portes de l'Europe le groupe RDSE et
en tout cas favorable à la hausse des
moyens de nos armées bien entendu les
arbitrages sont toujours difficiles car
ils ont le la précédente loi de
programmation a consisté à combler un
retard accumulé dans presque tous les
domaines l'équipement la préparation
opérationnelle leur enseignement ou
encore les conditions de la vie des
militaires s'agissant de la nouvelle
programmation dans le détail je relève
les améliorations intéressantes un
schéma d'emploi en hausse une batterie
de mesure pour attirer et fidéliser les
militaires
le renforcement des cibles de matériel
au bénéfice de nos trois armées et la
prise en compte des nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité à cet égard monsieur le
ministre j'observe dans le rapport
annexé la nécessité d'augmenter notre
capacité de surveillance et d'action
dans les espaces maritimes notamment les
plus
maîtrisés des fonds sous-marins en
profondeur de 6000 mètres
c'est une bonne chose compte tenu des
anges colossaux via les câbles
numériques les canalisations
alimentation de pétrole et au navigue
les drones sous-marins de surveillance
de défense et d'attaque je regrette que
cette compétence que posséder la France
il y a encore quelques années avec la
conception par les bureaux d'études de
Toulonnais que je connaissais bien du
sous-marin et 197 renommée aujourd'hui
le Nautil exploiter Paris freymère ne
soit pas mieux expliciter dans le LPM
pour améliorer plus significativement
notre capacité de surveillance et
d'intervention dans le milieu sous-marin
ça sera en quelque sorte ma question et
plus globalement je m'interroge comme la
fée la Commission depuis le début de ces
auditions sur la tonalité de la loi de
programmation cela a été dit l'étalement
des cibles de matériel et la question de
l'inflation de l'impact serait doré déjà
de 30 milliards d'euros invite pour le
moment mon groupe à attendre tous les
éléments demandés et évoqués en
commission pour se prononcer
définitivement sur le projet de loi de
militaire même si vous en avez apporté
aujourd'hui quelques-uns je vous
remercie
merci alors on va prendre le dernier
groupe Guillaume Gontard
merci garder les arguments pour la
séance prochaine où nous présenterons le
projet on n'est pas encore dans
l'expression définitive des groupes
avant le vote allons-y Guillaume merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre pour ce balayage large de cette
de cette LPM j'aurais pu effectivement
vous parler du tion ou du contrôle des
ventes mais effectivement on aura on
pourra avoir et on aura l'occasion
d'avoir d'avoir ce débat dont je voulais
aborder un sujet que vous avez juste
effleuré nous savons qu'à cause du
réchauffement climatique le nombre de
catastrophes naturelles que ce soit en
métropole en outre-mer vont augmenter
comme le rappelle le rapport du GIEC de
mars 2023 avec des aléas qui seront à la
fois plus
plus fort et plus fréquent que ça soit
des cyclones des sécheresses des
incendies des inondations des
glissements de terrain comme on a pu le
connaître avec la vallée de la Roya en
mais on sait aussi que les moyens
alloués à la sécurité civile reste
insuffisante et qu'on pourra pas ou en
tout cas difficilement palier à cette à
cette augmentation des aléas et donc ce
risque paraît apparaît en tout cas
nettement plus tangible et imminent qui
a conflit de haute intensité sur notre
sur notre sol et le ministre Béchu
récemment nous a même demandé de nous
adapter et de réfléchir à une adaptation
avec une augmentation de plus quatre
plus quatre degrés et donc considérant
l'apport justement de 413 milliards
d'euros aux armés et la volonté de
doubler la réserve opérationnelle
pensez-vous opportun que l'armée est
notamment cette réserve Vienne épauler
la sécurité civile avec la mise en place
de logistiques militaires pour
l'évacuation des populations sinistrées
le blocage de périmètre ou autre et si
oui cela évidemment impliquerait une
formation spécifique et la mise à
disposition de nouveaux moyens pour
faire face à ces à ces nouveaux enjeux
plus généralement ces enjeux d'aller
acclimatiques avec les conséquences sur
notre souveraineté qu'elles soient
alimentaires sanitaire énergétique
sont-ils pris en compte dans cette
nouvelle organisation et l'orientation
stratégique et des missions de nos
armées et ça va dans le sens d'ailleurs
de ce que disait Pierre Laurent sur quel
type d'armée et pourquoi faire en fait
on est en train de construire cette LPM
merci
allez on prend Dominique de lèche pour
la vie de la commission des finances
puis après le ministre répond et on
prendra les dernières questions minute
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre 3 trois points très rapidement
le premier point l'inflation vous nous
avez dit ça nous a été confirmé dans les
auditions que en gros elle représentait
30 milliards est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus sur entre guillemets la
répartition de cette inflation sur toute
la période parce que c'est de nature à
impacter notre lecture de la montée en
charge
deuxième point
l'outre-mer on a bien vu les raisons
stratégiques est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un tout petit peu plus à entrer
dans le détail mais sur ce que ça veut
dire concrètement sur le plan des
infrastructures temps liées au personnel
que les infrastructures liées au
matériel si je pose la question c'est
que pour mettre rendu à la Réunion et à
Mayotte je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait quand même un peu de travail à
faire donc ce serait peut-être bien que
vous puissiez nous en dire plus et
dernier point sur le Président je serai
pas plus long
Vous avez annoncé une rallonge
budgétaire d'un milliard 5 pour 2023
dans les auditions que j'ai pu faire et
notamment rapprochant de Bercy
j'ai pas senti une véritable
confirmation de cette somme est-ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui nous confirmer
qu'elle est bien prévu à quelle date
comment ça va arriver dans le budget des
armées à quoi saura-t-elle affectée et
est-ce qu'il faut la décompter dans les
400 ou les 413 milliards de la LPM je
vous remercie
le si tu veux la paix prépare la guerre
je l'ai jamais dit ça pour le coup ça
peut se dire moi j'ai une prudence là
dessus
il y a beaucoup de Parlement les
parlementaires une parole libre
moi je suis mise des armées autant que
le schéma dit pas ça
il parle de guerre d'avance par rapport
au modèle d'armée et aux sous
technologiques ce qui voilà mais la
guerre d'avance c'est pas pareil que si
tu veux la paix prépare la guerre c'est
la garde avant c'est de ne pas être prêt
pour la guerre d'hier c'est ça comme
Thierry Burkhard dit et la raison
en revanche si tu veux la paix prépare
la guerre c'est pas complètement la même
chose et je peux comprendre que ça
puisse heurter voilà parce que parce que
parce que de fait notre modèle d'armée
n'est pas un modèle d'agression
faut le dire j'étais frappé de voir des
amendements arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale j'espère je ne verrai pas les
mêmes ici ou au fond une espèce de ils
sont forcément guidés par un intérêt
industriel derrière parce que
franchement ça n'a aucun sens dire
certaines équipements enfin l'armée
française je vous le confirme monsieur
le Président l'armée française
n'envisage pas d'envahir les pays
limitrophes je le dis sur un ton
provoquant et badin mais je pense que
c'est utile aussi de redire ce qu'on
attend des armées et je pense que nous
nous sommes clairs pour le coup sur ce
qu'on attend des armées oui nous
considérons nous devons participer à
l'OTAN et au fait de dissuader des
agressions qui viendraient d'aller
extérieur de l'OTAN le compétiteur russe
on est un exemple le nomme il est dit la
lutte contre le terrorisme en Afrique ou
ailleurs c'est dit la liberté d'accès
maritime c'est dit les menaces cyber qui
peuvent venir de différents proxy c'est
dit je donc si vous estimez que le débat
n'a pas suffisamment eu lieu on peut de
nouveau l'avoir mais je pense qu'on a
quand même tous une appréciation de de
qui sont nos compétiteurs enfin je
l'espère
et d'où viennent les menaces et à la
rigueur si on ne peut pas s'accorder
d'où elles viennent au moins qu'on
s'accorde sur leur nature
la prolifération nucléaire existe peut
parler du Tian et du traité de nos
prolifération on y reviendra en séance
nous n'avons pas moi que vous avez au
moins de pays sur la planète qui sont en
situation de prolifération dont un pas
très loin de nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait
et ça c'est pas le nombre de chars qui
va régler le problème d'ailleurs bon
donc je dis nombre de griffons donc je
pense qu'il faut il faut se le dire moi
je suis prêt au débat mais je j'ai noté
cette nuit sur l'Afrique vous avez dit
vous même encore un instant quel
partenariat de sécurité avec les États
souverains en Afrique et vous ne pensez
pas que nos bases y concours moi je
pourrais vous démontrer que oui parce
que si on n'a pas des éléments
prépositionnés pour faire de la
formation en flux en permanence ce qu'on
fera sera
inefficace on peut envoyer un bataillon
de formation de temps en temps sans
force prépositionner on n'aura pas
l'effet de masse que les armées des pays
africains attendent de nous à la rigueur
je présente si on a des forces quels
sont leurs contrats est-ce qu'on fait de
la pluie au combat parce qu'on fait que
de la formation là je comprends la
question mais on n'arrive jamais à ce
niveau de débat pour autant je dis je
suis prêt
et c'est bien ce que je reproche et je
mets le pavé dans la main c'est aussi ce
que je reproche parfois sur les
conversations budgétaires que nous avons
eu c'est qu'en fait pendant qu'on parle
des marges frictionnelles on parle pas
de ces téléphones là qui est dans la
pièce et c'est ça qui est clé parce que
sinon on sait pas où s'arrêter on
demande de milliards pour le coup et ça
revient quand vous dites c'est quand
même beaucoup d'argent moi je partage
que vous dites les contribuable nous
concitoyens se posent des questions par
rapport à d'autres services publics et
on rendra un mauvais service aux armées
que d'opposer en plus les différents
budgets de la nation du service public
les uns avec les autres ce qu'il faut
c'est être capable d'avoir un budget
militaire qui correspond à notre défense
de nos intérêts vitaux de nos intérêts
tout court de notre sécurité et
peut-être d'intérêt qui concerne nos
alliés et c'est là on peut évidemment
avoir cette discussion
des capacités de projection oui
oui c'est aussi Sagittaire c'est ça
aussi les capacités de projection c'est
aussi barkhane
donc fallait pas répondre à aux demandes
des autorités maliennes quand il
s'agissait d'aller lutter contre le
terrorisme et de moi je soutiens je lui
ai dit cette muscle François Hollande a
décidé donc au bout d'un moment enfin je
pense qu'il faut aller dans le détail
justement de ces missions et du détail
des missions sur lequel on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec nous je vous sais je
voudrais comment de prendre hâte que la
copie est cohérente
tableau capacitaire les alliances etc
donc ça moi je pense c'est un point clé
la discussion de la programmation
militaire on peut toujours avoir des
débats sur les marches etc pendant des
heures à la fin des fins qu'est-ce qu'on
attend du modèle d'armée français et
peut toujours dire qu'il y a pas eu
assez de débats etc moi je le sentiment
qu'à chaque fois je reviens à chaque
fois qu'on voit qu'en tout cas avec
plaisir mais je pense qu'on peut l'avoir
et s'il faut suspendre cette présence
qui décide mais si un jour il faut
suspendre le et passer en mode huit lots
pour traiter certains sujets plus avant
je suis prêt à le faire devant vous je
pense que c'est démocratiquement
nécessaire
vraiment mais maintenant faut le faire
en dépêche je pense qu'on était précis
sur des GSE DRM et des SD je pense ça
n'écrase pas le débat pour l'avenir mais
je pense au moins que les objectifs sont
clairs on verra si on arrive à les
remplir mais en tout cas les objectifs
ils sont donnés donc là je suis prêt à
le faire y compris sur la dissuasion sur
la manière dont évidemment cette affaire
est et même je le fais d'ailleurs tout
de suite sur la dissasion strict
suffisance oui l'augmentation des
crédits enfin d'ailleurs c'est toujours
13% sauf que les crédits globaux
augmentent donc vous voyez qu'il y a une
bosse je l'ai pas caché tout à l'heure
dans mon propos ça vous avez raison de
me poser très précisément la question il
faudra y revenir il n'y a pas de remise
en question de la strict suffisance
ces sommes d'argent sont sur des
sauts technologiques de modernisation
pour que tout simplement la capacité à
dissuader soit toujours effectivement
pas besoin
d'en dire plus pour comprendre que si
certains pays muscles leur défense il
faut tout simplement que nous on muscle
les capacités tout simplement tout
simplement c'est aussi simple que ça que
dès lors que les capacités acoustiques à
entendre un sous-marin nucléaire sont de
plus en plus importantes et bien il est
clair que nous mettons plus d'argent
pour la discrétion c'est sous-marin
nucléaire bon pardon l'addition quelque
chose de frustrant ce qu'on ouvre
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets on n'arrive
pas à les emmener jusqu'au bout et d'une
audition à une autre après on se dit
qu'on va pas il y a pas assez de débat
on va pas au fond des choses donc sur la
dissuasion je me suis formé toute une
audition sur la dissuasion et le faire
moi je suis prêt à le faire mais le
débat nous nous sommes cohérents à
droite d'accord avec nous mais nous
sommes cohérents la vraie question c'est
de savoir ce que quelle est l'utilité
d'avoir 3000 têtes nucléaires dans
certains pays sachant que après en avoir
utilisé cinq qui n'existent plus alors
donc alors les pays en question on la
réponse à cette question mais je la
reprendrai pas dans ma bouche
en tout cas nous la stricte suffisance
et ça je me réengage aux affaires
monsieur le Président Laurent reste
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre doctrine
strictement défensive de protection des
intérêts vitaux d'une menace venant d'un
agresseur étatique voilà pour dire les
choses de manière précise monsieur le
sénateur viol sur font sous-marin etc on
y reviendra il y a des enjeux importants
parce que sur la capacité à 6000 mètres
des entreprises de votre région et de
votre département d'ailleurs ce qu'on
concernait sans compter que c'est à la
langue des morts que en plus sera
installé le slot de naval group on
pourra y revenir de manière plus précise
mais évidemment c'est clé cela
soutenabilité financière tu as plus ta
copie est cohérente
tout de parler des 30 milliards sur
l'inflation on va moi je pense que je
vais vous écrire sur la manière dont
Bercy et le ministère des armées à
construire justement les hypothèses de
des 30 milliards qui permet de voir
quels sont les indicateurs sur lequel ça
repose
qui sont effectivement des indicateurs
très dégradés dire personne ne me pose
la question si on avait une inversement
de la tendance qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
libertés d'action que l'on va retrouver
ben non parce que c'est en programmation
donc ça sera au bénéfice du ministère et
d'ailleurs si j'étais taquin c'est bien
le problème c'est que en tout cas tant
que je serai mis des armées j'y
veillerai c'est de ne pas aller vers des
bourrages excessifs c'est toute la LPM
2018 actuelle vous aviez des facteurs
macroéconomiques étaient bons et sur
lequel pour de bonnes raisons Florence
Parly à procéder à des investissements
qui n'étaient pas prévus dans la LPM le
cyber en est un des grands exemples et
le spatial parce que fallait faire vite
et de pas rater le train et de fait
c'est pas dans la programmation initiale
le fort-9 de Vincennes pour la DGSE
aussi pour être complètement précis et
complet donc vous avez des éléments qui
ne sont pas dans la programmation et
dont l'aisance macro budgétaires de la
LPM a permis de les programmer alors
qu'il n'était pas programmé
la réalité c'est que je laisserai
sûrement à me successeurs une
programmation qui sera particulièrement
détendue aussi de ce point de vue
puisqu'on a pris des critères qui sont
très pessimistes c'est très défavorable
mais ça je vais peut-être le détailler
par écrit pour redonner les perspectives
de cette affaire
sachant que pour le milliard 5
évidemment ça ne se déduit pas des 413
puisque 413 2024-2030 on reste en
gestion l'idée justement alors je sais
pas quand est-ce que le collectif
budgétaire arrivera ça je ne suis pas
compétent pour répondre à cette question
là mais en 23 en tout cas cette chose
doit être traité il est clair que pour
nous c'est un moyen de faire aussi le
tulage entre les deux LPM voilà et que
ça permet de faire déterminaisons
budgétaires que le cas échéant pourrait
on pourrait aussi peut-être développer
par ailleurs monsieur le sénateur
Gontard monsieur le Président routard
pardon
sur réchauffement je suis plus rapide
mais sur réchauffement climatique c'est
un sujet clé et pour le coup ça répond
aussi aux questions du président Laurent
sur les contrats opérationnels on peut
pas ne pas voir que héphaïsto ça a été
imaginé pour quelques départements bien
précis pour lutter contre les incendies
et feux de forêt l'été en particulier et
désormais effet histo c'est aussi
l'hiver et dans le département Nord de
la Loire
tout est dit c'est un premier exemple le
deuxième exemple c'est une lutte armée
terrible c'est probablement une des plus
belles missions que l'armée française
accomplie même si elle est difficile
c'est harpie scandale environnemental
que leur paillage illégal scandale
sanitaire scandale humanitaire les
forces armées et les gendarmes sont
engagés on est sur des sujets biodivers
on est sur des sujets de souveraineté je
pense que c'est intéressant pour le coup
et beaucoup d'OMG comme vous le savez en
plus seront mobilise sur cette question
et les ont bien raison et ça c'est
évidemment des exemples et puis je pense
que nous on a un devoir majeur sur les
l'aide aux autres pays je pense que dans
la dopacifique Center mal au pointé sur
une audition précédente il est clair que
dans les micro-États du Pacifique le
génie militaire pour gérer des
catastrophes naturelles à être un enjeu
pour ces pays majeurs et sur les
outre-mer c'est là où nous on doit
positionner plus de force pour être en
capacité dans solidarité d'agir dans les
micro-étales la région en tout cas là il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de sujets qui sont
sur la table et je vous passe le fait
que le ministère des armées lui-même
doit davantage montrer l'exemple c'est
un grand propriétaire foncier de
beaucoup de passoires énergétiques on a
beaucoup de zones Natura 2000 la
question de la gestion de l'eau j'ai pas
le temps de tout détailler mais enfin il
faut tout simplement aussi que le
ministère des armées soit exemplaire
comme ministère et ça aussi je pourrais
le cas échéance si vous le souhaitez en
séance et revenir dans le détail vous
avez vu que vos collègues et homologues
groupes homologues du de l'Assemblée
nationale de votre sensibilité politique
a fait voter des amendements d'ailleurs
à l'unanimité parce que plutôt une bonne
chose sera la première LPM qui quand
même pointera ses sujets dans le texte
et à mon avis c'est clé parce qu'on peut
pas dissocier des hormones sujet
climatiques des sujets de sécurité par
ailleurs flux migratoires pêchent
illégal les sujets liotiques là aussi
qui sont à la fois environnementaux et
souveraineté donc de fait on pourra
avoir un beau débat sur le sujet il se
rendra grande partie satisfait monsieur
sénateur de l'outre-mer
pour le coup on est dans le territoire
national c'est juste d'acter qu'il y a
des menaces qui sont spécifiques
soit
soit une menace spécifique liée à
l'environnement régional du territoire
d'outre-mer concerné
parle beaucoup de Mayotte avec les
Comores enfin on pourrait aussi beaucoup
parler de Mayotte dans l'embouchure du
golf du Mozambique et du terrorisme
Mozambique sujet dont on ne parle jamais
à Paris et on a bien tort je parlais de
pêche illégale il est évident que c'est
un énorme change en jeu pardon dans
l'océan Indien ou dans l'océan Pacifique
parce qu'on a une pression démographique
en Asie qui fait qu'on a des flottilles
de pêche qui vont de plus en plus loin
et qui sont de plus en plus agressifs
qui sont à mi-parcours entre une pêche
illégale et le début de quelque chose
qui pourrait s'apparenter à une forme de
terrorisme des mers tellement les
techniques sont agressives et violentes
tuées pour péché ça c'est quand même des
cas pratiques dans lequel les Français
sont pas confrontés à ça aujourd'hui
pour cause on a des forces qui font un
travail remarquable mais vous aurez un
niveau de dureté qui va s'installer dans
la durée 5 10 15 20 ans comment vous
avez une doctrine dans pas de vos forces
qui permet de le faire les sujets liés
au tyrannie des distances la 401 pour le
coup changera beaucoup la donne mais
quel est le bon équilibre entre les
forces que vous proposez sur le
territoire concerné et qu'est-ce que
vous mettez avec les fonds national
d'urgence en réactivité aux coups de
départ depuis Paris pour remplir un
certain nombre de missions ça ça pose
aussi la question des équilibres entre
les missions de court séjour et de long
séjour dans les territoires d'outre-mer
la question des nouvelles technologies
ou en fait jadis les outre-mer sont là
où le matériel est le plus vêtu c'était
le plus ancien par le cohérence et de
masse c'est là où c'est le plus infernal
dans les mauvais en masse et on est très
mauvais en cohérence pour le coup dans
les territoires d'outre-mer c'est pour
ça que j'ai souhaité de là où je venais
de mes fonctions ministères précédentes
faire un nombre d'hélicoptère et
satisfaisant nombre d'hélicoptère qui
volent vraiment les beaucoup moins c'est
un exemple très concret et les nouvelles
technologies la Polynésie est grande
comme l'Europe les nouvelles canonique
grande comme l’autriche et la Guyane
grande comme le Portugal si c'est pas là
où les imageries spatiales ou les drones
doivent trouver évidemment leur terrain
en application on marcherait à l'envers
donc on aura l'occasion de revenir sur
l'outre-mer mais c'est un défi
complètement spécifique qui répond aussi
aux questions d'ailleurs là encore du
président Laurent c'est oui là il y a
des cas pratiques sécuritaires
qui sont propres territoires d'outre-mer
et c'est la France donc il faut le
traiter est-ce qu'une LPM il suffira non
parce que les outre-mer sont
malheureusement aussi confrontés à
l'hybridité et donc tous les enjeux
cybers qui vont s'étaler sur 10-15 ans
parce que c'est la maille est là pour le
coup en termes de sous technologie devra
aussi concerner évidemment les
territoires d'outre-mer
merci alors avec l'objectif de conclure
véritablement à 19h c'est-à-dire dans 20
minutes au total j'ai 5 questions
minutes avec des réponses concises
Olivier Cadic merci monsieur le ministre
pour vos propos gagner la guerre avant
la guerre c'est la formule utilisée par
le Sénat c'est une approche qui me
convient et qui a fait ses preuves
concernant la guerre froide vous m'avez
promis la réponse oubliée hier soir sur
l'Algérie 93% des ressources algériennes
proviennent du Sud algérien pour la
première fois depuis 17 ans le chef
d'état-major algérien s'est rendu en
France comment analyse-t-il la situation
sécuritaire au Sahel depuis le retrait
de barkhane et envisage-t-il une
coopération militaire la LPM prévoit
pour un budget de 4 milliards d'euros
pour le cyber pour la période 2024 2030
c'est un effort qui mérite d'être
souligné pour ma part j'ai été très
agréablement surpris et rassuré par le
niveau des capacités présentées à Rennes
pour répondre au défi cyber le
département de la Défense américain a
lancé initiative en 2022 pour un Claude
de défense intitulé zéro trust référence
architecture qui prévoit d'associer les
grands noms américains de l'Internet
j'ai reçu en audition hier Philips Tupac
directeur fédéral de la cybersécurité à
la Maison Blanche qui m'a éclairé sur ce
projet je remercie nos alliés américains
de leur coopération avec le Parlement
français et leur marque de considération
et de confiance la Maison Blanche a
annoncé une augmentation du budget de la
cyber de 5 milliards de dollars sur par
an l'augmentation Philippe tupac a
répondu à ma question sur leur budget
annuel dans ce domaine il est sans
commune mesure avec notre budget cyber
prévu pour les 6 ans de la LPM est-ce
qu'une démarche similaire au Cloud de
défense américain est envisagé à quel
niveau et sur quel budget
je fais tac au tac et moi je me
discipline maintenant sinon vraiment je
change je vais être un populaire Algérie
oui c'est une discussion permanente avec
eux je les remercie publiquement parce
que sur le déménagement de barkhane du
Mali vers le Niger ils nous ont été du
net très précieuse 200 en dire plus les
services de renseignement travaillent
bien ensemble parce que globalement
c'est tout l'intérêt et de l'Algérie et
de la France que de contenir évidemment
les menaces sécurité terroristes qui
pourraient remonter trois l'Algérie a eu
quand même des efforts importants lutte
contre le terrorisme et là-dessus nous
sont gré et pour le coup en privé
certains m'ont fait même des
commentaires en disant qu'il trouvait
que les commentaires à Paris entendus
sur barkham leur semblait bien dur et
bien injuste par rapport justement
sacrifice de nos soldats pour dire les
choses très clairement et donc on tient
le contact avec le gouvernement algérien
renseignement cyber merci pour l'émo sur
brut parce que c'est un travail
important qu'à mener la DGA Jean-Yves Le
Drian etc tout ça avance bien cloud oui
il y a des projets similaires qui sont
présents dans la LPM après faut-il
comparer nos moyens et ceux des
Américains par définition ça c'est
limite et ben voilà on y arrive Hélène
Conway allez on garde le rythme
dans le débat finalement et dans le
détail de la LPM je voudrais simplement
vous demander de clarifier un point qui
est un point d'inquiétude pour nous et
qui est la concomitance du développement
d'un certain nombre d'équipements
majeurs et du renouvellement de la
dissuasion nucléaire on se demande si
c'est concomitant finalement est
réaliste et comment nous allons faire
financièrement pour tout faire en même
temps et est-ce que l'engagement de ces
crédits ne va pas se faire finalement
puisqu'ils sont assez conséquents au
détriment des petits programmes et puis
deux petits points des gens en profiter
pour faire passer un message puisque
lors des auditions nous avons entendu
des industriels qui sont dans cette
logique donc d'économie de guerre
c'est-à-dire produire plus et plus vite
mais qui se plaignent tous finalement
d'un manque de compétences d'un besoin
criant en matière d'ouvriers spécialisés
de techniciens d'ingénieurs est-ce qu'il
n'est pas tant aujourd'hui finalement de
promouvoir l'attractivité des métiers de
l'industrie de défense et de fait
d'avoir une mobilisation générale et
donc mobilisation des ministères autres
que le ministère de la Défense pour
répondre à ces à ses besoins et dernier
point je crois qu'il est très important
monsieur le ministre en effet de
rappeler que la France n'a aucune
ambition hégémonique et que finalement
aujourd'hui notre présence en Afrique et
bien là pour répondre aux besoins de nos
partenaires et là je m'inscris en à
l'opposé de de finalement de la réponse
de livicadique de dire oui il faudrait
dès lors que nous avons un problème que
nos militaires puissent répondre je
crois que finalement c'est ce qu'on nous
a reproché et critiquer à tort de nous
dire que nous étions là pour nous-mêmes
nous ne sommes pas là pour nous-mêmes et
au Mali nous n'étions pas là pour
nous-mêmes nous sommes allés au Mali
parce que nous avons répondu à une
demande et donc je pense que à l'avenir
nous devons vraiment marteler ce comment
ce vocabulaire de partenariat il y a un
outil extrêmement intéressant à Abidjan
qui est l'Académie internationale de
lutte contre le terrorisme voilà quelque
chose qui va servir sur le plan régional
mais également sur le plan international
et c'est la France et la Côte d'Ivoire
qui finalement aujourd'hui sont engagés
dans le développement de de cet outil là
donc voilà c'est simplement un exemple
je pense sur lequel nous nous pouvons
travailler développer d'autres merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre inquiétude équipement majeur
dissuasion nucléaire non tout est bien
dans la copie de toute façon déjà un
parfois vous n'avez pas le choix
la scorpionisation on est au bout du
bout de ce qu'on peut attendre des
vagues dont on vient aussi à la
cohérence opérationnelle versus
s'organise je recommence pas mais c'est
prévu deux parfois c'est lié si on
parlerafal il fait partie des contrats
opérationnels pour la dissuasion et pour
cause pour les forces administratives
donc quand on bascule sur le Tour infâle
à la fois vous vous satisfaisez la
partie conventionnelle et en même temps
la partie la partie nucléaire donc s'il
y a des inquiétudes moi je suis preneur
de
tout dépenser en même temps c'est prévu
ça fonctionne après pardon c'est là
aussi où la réparation plus la
transformation et la rénovation
demandent des efforts et des choix mais
une fois de plus on est reparti des
contrats opérationnels ça pendant la
discussion séance j'aimerais pour vous
en faire la démonstration à chaque fois
les petits programmes nous au contraire
une a beaucoup l'innovation d'ailleurs
permet de laider tout ça ça avance bien
les capacités et les perspectives qu'on
donnait à la bit des permet aussi de
manière incrémentale et sur fonds
propres de prendre quelques risques en
la matière là aussi on pourra peut-être
en donner quelques exemples s'il faut
dans le rapport indexé faire un
amendement pour en donner des exemples
de petits programmes qui sont
intéressants et compris par exemple pour
les Forces Spéciales moi je suis prêt à
le faire typiquement c'est un bon
exemple de ce qu'on cherche à faire et
pour l'attractivité de la BITD ça c'est
un point très très juste pour des
raisons de souligner 3 BITD manque de
compétences c'est un énorme combat alors
déjà c'est un combat industriel français
peu importe ce qu'on vend et la nature
même de l'industrie je crois que en ce
moment c'est il y a quand même une
tension sur le marché de l'emploi qu'il
faut noter
2 je pense qu'on a un effort collectif
et culturel à faire c'est arrêter de
pointer du doigt les marchands pour être
tout à fait clair parce que on voit bien
pour l'accès au financement bancaire
comme pour l'attractivité en matière de
de Job enfin en tout cas de ressources
humaines c'est sûr qu'au bout d'un
moment ce sont pas des métiers qui sont
toujours forcément valorisés
sociétalement parlant enfin on parle
plus de RSE d'un côté que de patriotisme
industriel militaire si j'ose dire or
notre modèle repose sur ça et donc je
pense que là aussi peut-être une
réflexion collective à avoir en la
matière en tout cas c'est clé présent
Laurent est parti mais je quand on dit
aussi la question c'est beaucoup
d'argent faut aussi redire au Parti
communiste français que c'est la c'est
aussi de la contribution avec nos
industries de défense qui sont présents
en 4 coins du pays si on a acheté à
Moscou Washington ou Pékin forcément ça
coûterait moins cher peut-être encore
que c'est pas certain donc
voilà donc il faut aussi réexpliquer le
modèle global de la BITD avec ces
tensions et ses contraintes dont la
question est ressources humaines c'est
pour ça évidemment il y a la question
des réserves pour dustrie qui peut se
poser à des investielle de défense on
pourra aussi y revenir et puis
clairement j'ai aussi dit au patron de
la BTD que avec les perspectives qu'ils
avaient sans faire le grand soir il fait
le site qui soit capable d'intéresser
leurs salariés à la performance au
cadence enfin je veux dire il faut tout
ça aussi soit très global et
transversale parce que ça participe
aussi à acceptabilité sociétale des
dépenses militaires
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale a montré les défis d'ampleur
auxquels sont confrontés nos armées sur
le prend le plan de l'attractivité des
métiers et la fidélisation des
militaires nous avons une armée de
grande envergure elle a sur une
formation initiale et continue de nos
militaires ainsi que le personnel civil
formation de grande qualité qui les
rendent très attractifs sur le marché de
l'emploi vous l'avez rappelé lors de
votre intervention il est essentiel de
revaloriser les grilles indiciaires et
d'accroître leur progressivité en
augmentant leur indice brut pouvez-vous
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur ces
améliorations je vous remercie
pardon les grilles indiciaires
sujets clés
de la phrase c'est pour ça j'avais pas
compris
le rehaussement du niveau du SMIC a et
c'est une bonne nouvelle entraîner le
rehaussement de la solde de la troupe du
soldat très bien
moyennant quoi comme la réflexion n'a
pas été née dans l'ensemble vous avez
les grilles indiciaires des différents
grappes qui s'est assez avec le temps et
donc l'écart entre globalement la solde
d'un première classe caporal
caporal-chef avec la solde d'un sergent
d'un sergent-chef ou second maître etc
pour la marine au fond c'est
considérablement tassé et dans le même
moment jamais nos armées n'ont confié
autant de responsabilités à nos
sous-officiers technologique
décisionnelle etc et là vous avez un
espèce de Gap terrible qui a un impact
sur la fidélisation qui est de dire
attendez moi j'ai des responsabilités je
suis pas mieux payé ou je suis caporal
caporal-chef pourquoi j'irai m'ennuyer
et devenir sous-officier parce que les
différences de soldes sont à ce point
résiduel
et donc au fond c'est là pourquoi je
vous donne les grappes parce que la
tentation que certains pourraient avoir
aussi ont eu l'Assemblée nationale c'est
faire un grand saupoudrage en
choisissant pas ce qui peut permettre
d'être faussement populaire pendant 5 ou
10 minutes mais ça ne remplit pas les
effets désirés et les effets désirés
c'est de se dire les sujets délimitaires
et sujets de grille indiciaire après les
sujets de point d'indice de la fonction
publique c'est encore un autre sujet
mais en tout cas sur la grille
indiciaire sur l'indemnitaire il faut y
travailler pour justement être capable
de recréer des vrais seuils qui soient
attractifs pour l'ensemble de nos
soldats qui prennent des responsabilités
et ça c'est un point très clair qui
au-delà des grades ensuite de sa
compagnie par de l'indemnité parce que
vous voulez libérer quand vous êtes
sous-officier sur un sous-marin ou sur
certaines fonctions de combat c'est pas
complètement la même chose que si vous
êtes dans d'autres fonctions donc là
aussi il faut qu'on donne un peu plus de
souplesse donc il y a les sommes
d'argent il y a les grilles mais aussi
la manière dont on déclenche tout ça
aussi dans une subsidiarité dans la
chaîne de commandement qui permet aussi
tout simplement d'avoir des outils c'est
vrai par exemple pour le cyber
combattant dont on voit bien que ils
sont chassés pour aller intégrer des
entreprises privées et donc il faut
évidemment être être en capacité de le
faire voilà de manière la plus
synthétique possible à une question qui
mériterait un développement beaucoup
plus long même la signature
oui merci monsieur le Président
sur le ministre tout d'abord excusez-moi
mon élocution
je voulais faire une remarque et poser
une question
la remarque c'est que depuis 2002 j'ai
suivi toutes les lois de programmation
militaire et je peux vous dire que
celle-ci est une exercice quand même qui
est certainement plus facile et plus
intéressant regardez moyen par rapport à
des lois de programmation militaire à
passer et donc acte par rapport à cela
ma question
à la fin
du cycle dernier les forces de
souveraineté étaient de l'ordre de 15000
au début de la loi de programmation
militaire précédente elles étaient au
sein d'un tour de 8300 aujourd'hui elles
sont un millier de moins dans le cadre
de des discussions à l'Assemblée
nationale je crois que c'était la Linéa
47 de l'article 2 donc du annexé il a
été dit que les outre-mer sont un
impératif de la loi de programmation
militaire finalement pour vous qu'est-ce
que c'est cette notion d'impératif de la
loi de programmation militaire comment
cela va-t-il se concrétiser merci
mais merci beaucoup monsieur sénateur
bon rétablissement pour la voie
c'est plus intéressant quand les moyens
augmentent c'est certain vous voyez bien
quand même que ça déclenche aussi des
discussions qui sont plus redoutables et
plus complexes parce que faire les choix
de où est-ce que cet argent doit aller
c'est pas si consensuel en fonction des
intérêts des autres ou des
choix aussi industriels d'ailleurs il
faut bien le reconnaître qu'ils peuvent
être derrière et puis la deuxième
particularité c'est que le contexte
stratégique évidemment
indopacifique que vous connaissez bien
et puis évidemment la question de
l'Ukraine mais aussi tout ce que j'ai
déjà pu indiquer terrorisme donc ça
forme évidemment un ensemble de critères
et d'éléments liés aux circonstances qui
font évidemment que la discussion de
cette loi s'inscrit dans un moment de
gravité et de vérité qui est assez
similaire à d'autres temps qu'on a pu
connaître dans le passé sur les forces
de souveraineté enfin surtout sur la
question était sur outre-mer et
souveraineté de manière claire j'ai
commencé à répondre un peu sénateur de
l'âge sur ce sujet
il y a des menaces qui sont communes à
l'Hexagone et au territoire d'outre-mer
très bien il y a quand même des menaces
qui sont spécifiques par l'environnement
régional disais-je j'ai cité l'exemple
du terrorisme aux zombie avec Mayotte
première exemple à la pêche illégal dans
quelque chose pour être un bon
connaisseur d'État on voit bien qu'on a
de plus en plus des enjeux de
contestation soit des concessions
diplomatiques soit des concessions de
fait tout simplement de groupes privés
le cas échéant qui viennent aussi tester
notre capacité à assumer notre
souveraineté donc ça pour le coup ça va
repasser par des contrats opérationnels
qui vont se durcir c'est vraiment en
matière maritime en matière aérien mais
aussi en matière de présence terrestre
mieux répartir me semble-t-il sur les
territoires je sors le sujet avec harpie
qui correspond à un modèle
d'organisation qui est bien spécifique
et qui lui est propre mais typiquement
pour les fans les forces armées en
Nouvelle-Calédonie vous êtes sur un
modèle qui s'est beaucoup replié sur
Nouméa ce que je déplore et sur lequel
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on soit capable de
nouveau d'être dans une stratégie de
déploiement qui soit différente et un
peu dans ce qu'on a dit pour le
président Gontard c'est à dire aussi
d'intégrer les questions du
réchauffement climatique dans les
missions je pense que les métiers du
génie par exemple vont désormais
participer encore davantage à une
capacité d'assurer d'assumer notre
souveraineté puis enfin il y a toutes
les nouvelles technologies pardon de
faire vite tu le fais hyper vite la
question par exemple la surveillance
spatiale a les clés pour nos territoires
d'outre-mer pour les questions maritimes
pour les taf que vous connaissez une
fois de plus très bien il est clair que
pour le coup le satellite d'observation
devront faire plus demain voilà pardon
mais en quelques en deux minutes c'est
quasiment impossible de faire une
réponse plus satisfaisante que celle-ci
le président merci sur le ministre
question commune avec mon collègue
vogrenard focal sur le 144
augmentation des crédits pour les études
amont sur la durée de la LPM nous en
étions
réjouis avec de l'ordre de 10% de
croissance mais sur la chronique des
crédits annuels on s'aperçoit qu'en 2024
et jusqu'à 2027 on est sur un montant en
net diminution avec une reprise
au-dessus du milliard d'euros qu'à
partir de 2028 c'est en tout cas le
tableau qui nous a été
transmis oui on ne l'invente pas bien
évidemment donc non seulement c'est un
effort en fin de votre programmation
mais aussi une régression sur la
situation actuelle mais c'est peut-être
une erreur administrative et auquel cas
on s'en réjouira et sur les services de
renseignement 11000 postes créés
1100 postes créés pardon 11 ce serait
fantastique mais on pourrait pas les
avoir le problème de ce qui nous ressort
des auditions c'est la difficulté de
recruter et de fidéliser et une fuite
aussi des contractuels le coordonnateur
national du renseignement et de la lutte
contre le terrorisme détient une
compétence en matière de coordination
interministérielle des politiques de
ressources humaines des services de
renseignement alors sans empiéter
peut-être sur les politiques propres à
chaque service est-ce qu'il y aurait pas
là une légitimité de ce comité
interministériel pour élaborer une
politique de ressources humaines
interministérielle appuyez sur une
politique publique de renseignement afin
d'homogénéiser les rémunérations de
construire des parcours professionnels
et de mutualiser les formations
suggestion merci beaucoup monsieur
sénateur alors tout augmente sur une en
plus j'ai parlé de vous tout à l'heure
sur l'innovation tout augmente en
revanche un point clé peut-être pour la
lecture en fait certains périmètres ont
donc faites bien de poser la question et
on va régler les périmètres mais il n'y
a pas une ligne qui ne demande pas de
toute façon à l'année N+1 on va prendre
des bases du rythme d'augmentation mais
ça c'est clair comme je vous l'avais dit
sur le tableau capacitaire j'ai préféré
désormais un tableau qui cible ce qui
est existe dans le format des armées un
tableau de parc pour des raisons
démocratique ça me semble légitime
plutôt qu'un tableau de commande après
tout on fait pas fait pas la guerre avec
un bon de commande on fait la guerre
avec un matériel qu'on nous a livré et
après on fait la guerre avec un matériel
quand vous allez livrer qui fonctionne
c'est la DT du sénateur sigurique bon
donc ça je pense que si on fait la
boucle non mais c'est important parce
que dans on peut pas avoir le contrôle
démocratique du Parlement si un moment
donné et moi je suis en train de faire
ce travail qu'on fait sur la DTO où je
suis en train de réaffiner tous ces
indicateurs et ses critères qui parfois
datent de mettre du CM il faut bien le
reconnaître
CNRT
alors elle est placée pour le coup ça
reste de l'organique et donc ça reste
quand même les ministères compétents
c'est normal d'ailleurs
et peut-être encore plus pour le mien
dans la mesure où vous avez des sujets
qui sont propres statut militaires et
vous avez des sujets qui sont propres
pour le coup ou civils
je pense que la DGSE a un travail
important de fidélisation là où
évidemment la pente est de réclamer des
ETP que par ailleurs ils ont obtenu et
c'est bien naturel et c'est
indispensable néanmoins là aussi il y a
un enjeu de d'épaisseur et moi pour
avoir rencontré beaucoup d'agents qui
parfois ont voulu partir ou sont partis
parfois c'est pour des choses qui sont
un peu dérisoires qui sont partis à la
fois leur faisait des bons d'or dans le
privé est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut concurrencer non pour autant
parfois ils sont partis parce qu'on leur
refusé ou ils n'ont pas obtenu 150 euros
d'augmentation qui permettait de payer
une facture qui n'arrivait pas à payer
par là dans leur vie personnelle ça vaut
pas système que je dis ça ça ne veut pas
généralisation mais il est clair que
dans les sommes que vous apprêtez à
examiner dans le cadre de la
programmation il y a des outils qui vont
permettre à chaque employeur public au
sein du ministère de trouver des
solutions de fidélisation sachant qu'un
amendement est adopté à l'Assemblée en
plus sur la part de militarité de la
DGSE parce que un des moyens aussi de
fidéliser c'est tout simplement aussi de
s'assurer cette militarité qui est quand
même a bien des égards peut être
attractif et le métier du cyber est
aussi un métier de combattant par
ailleurs voilà on synthèse
un mot de très rapidement mais je peux
pas ne pas en parler monsieur le
ministre ça concerne les rues je vous ai
interrogé à de nombreuses reprises il y
a quelques bruits qui circulent qui me
disent que la DGA serait sur le point
rapidement de
contracter un marché d'appel d'offre
européen ça veut dire en gros qui met
les conditions pour extraire et pour
mettre de côté une solution souveraine
c'est pas des c'est pas des ondits que
ce soit clair moi je voudrais qu'on soit
très clair sur le sujet vous avez été
très clair lorsque vous avez dit que
vous alliez dégager 600 millions d'euros
et que vous allez demander à la DGA que
vous ne serez pas un bon mini si vous ne
le faisiez pas vous me l'avez dit entre
quatre yeux demandez l'étude très claire
et très sérieuse d'une solution
souveraine je le dis ici claire et net
si toutefois le RFI se fait et si on va
sur un appel de Fort européen et il est
clair qu'on passera jamais sur un
solution souveraine française donc je
voudrais qu'on garantisse les choses on
le fera dans le cadre de la LPM je le
dis aussi mais en tout cas c'est un
sujet quand même très important merci
beaucoup
c'est une bonne question alors ça m'a
permis de revenir sur le pot régiment
d'artillerie de Belfort au hasard
du Territoire de Belfort donc vous êtes
le sénateur ma géographie
non moi je vous le redis
c'était la conversion qu'on a vu donc ça
me permet de le relire publiquement
le principe doit être une solution
souveraine avec le principe ici
exception ça serait pour des raisons
opérationnelles et donc faut pas
raconter une histoire ça serait du
heimar ça américain et pas autre chose
donc pas d'appel d'offres européens etc
moi je forme le vœu pour qu'on puisse
avoir une solution souveraine et c'est
là où j'ai demandé la DGA comme vous le
savez mais je le redis c'est de
objectiver le coûte bon mais 600
millions d'euros sont dans la copie
le délai
le modèle à l'export parce que si on se
lance une solution souveraine on serait
mauvais là aussi si on ne regarde pas
tout de suite la capacité à être bon ça
veut dire que si c'est ça c'est quoi sa
spécificité militaire est-ce que c'est
un mars français ou est-ce que c'est un
peu autre chose c'est pas une
intéressante d'avoir la conversation
d'autant plus que je vous le rappelle
les rues une partie du châssis était
déjà américain donc on n'a jamais été
complètement 100% souverain dans cette
affaire après ça vous empêcherait que le
présent République a parlé des frappes
dans la profondeur la semaine dernière
lors de son intervention sur le la
communauté politique européenne on voit
bien défendre solaire et frappe dans la
profondeur
sont quand même deux éléments du combat
opérationnel et du combat terrestre ou
érothérèse en tout cas demain qui est
absolument clé donc voilà je vous
rassure sur le point en revanche sur le
calendrier de retour de la DGA je ne
sais vous dire en tout cas s'il y a des
moi non plus
en tout cas en tout cas s'il faut redire
ou spécifier ce que je viens de dire
c'est en clair il y a le principe et
l'exception ce qui me semble le bon
ratio de dans la prise de risque et dans
les équilibres de risques vous avez vu
vos artilleurs sur dans votre dans le
régiment de votre territoire à la fois
il y aurait de la fierté avoir un
dispositif français et en même temps sur
leur dire qu'il arrive dans 10 ans on
aura un problème pour être clair quoi
donc c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
documenter et éclairer et je le dis en
assumant collectivement une prise de
risque parce que j'ai souvent soulevé à
l'Assemblée nationale où je découvre une
forme d'aversion au risque dans les
choix politiques et militaires une fois
de plus c'est tout notre modèle robot
sur une prise de risque en acceptant des
retards des délais des aléas des
incertitudes c'est ainsi
monsieur le ministre merci infiniment
merci à mes collègues parce que je
décomptais près de 6h d'audition en
comptant évidemment les la séance de ce
matin je pourrais y rajouter les
questions au Gouvernement et pour ma
part le ministre des Affaires étrangères
de Hongrie des 8h30 ce matin donc on a
passé une bonne journée merci infiniment
je veux simplement
souligner en un seul mot le désir une
nouvelle fois renouvelée de tous nos
collègues d'une grande transparence sur
les éléments que vous nous donnez à
faire des DTO tout ça a été évoqué voyez
on veut on veut vous accompagner dans
cette loi qui évidemment nous intéresse
et intéresse les armées mais pour ça
donnez-nous les éléments qui nous
permettront de vous suivre vous
accompagner et d'exercer la mission
constitutionnelle qui est la nôtre je
pense que les messages ont été bien
compris et ça facilitera grandement les
choses si dans les trois semaines qui
nous conduisent à l'examen en séance que
ce soit pour les groupes que ce soit
pour le bureau moi-même on puisse avoir
tous les réponses aux éléments que l'on
vous a demandé et pas de réponse
dilatoire parce que ça ne sert à rien et
ça fait que que gêné le travail de nos
collègues merci infiniment
et donc maintenant chacun va continuer à
travailler pour préparer
une belle séance en
hémicycle je ne sais pas le la quantité
de temps qu'il faudrait consacrer
puisque ça dépend aussi de la du nombre
d'amendements enfin ici la composition
politique de s'assemblée fait qu'il y a
une série de séries d'amendements qu'on
a pas vraiment merci à vous